TO TRY TO START WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO WE CAN'T DO THE
VOTE ITEMS.
WHEN WE DO GET A QUORUM WILL
INTERRUPT THEIR PRESENTATIONS SO
THAT WE CAN TO THE VOTE ITEMS
ONLY. US SEVERAL BAND MEMBERS
ARE IN OTHER COMMITTEES MAKING
PRESENTATIONS AS WELL AS
WHATEVER SO.
AND ALL OF US I DON'T HAVE TO
BE IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE TO SO.
I'M NOT RIGHT NOW BUT FAIRLY
SOON SO WE WANT TO BEGIN WITH A
BEGIN HEARING ITEMS THAT ARE
MEMBER ITEMS.
.
THAT.
MANY OF YOU HAVE MADE REQUEST
AND IT'S JOIN MY PRACTICE ALLOW
MEMBERS TO MAKE A BRIEF
PRESENTATION TO THE COMMITTEE IF
WE HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS WE CAN.
ANSWER THEM BUT WE WON'T HAVE
LONG PRESENTATIONS AND
TESTIMONIES AND ALL THAT STUFF
SO.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN A FIRST
PERSON LUIS IS MISTER ARAMBULA.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
THE THE YOUR REQUESTS WHICH HAS
TO DO WITH.
.
PUBLIC SAFETY AND.
TRACE OKAY GOOD.
SO YOU.
WILL BE WE'RE GIVING EACH
MEMBER FIVE MINUTES TO EXPLAIN
THEIR REQUEST
THE BE ON THE RECORD I THINK THE
MEMBERS WILL HAVE COPIES OF IT.
WE HAVEN'T MADE ANY DECISIONS
CONCERNING THE FUNDING OF ANY OF
THE REQUEST YET WE'LL SEE WHERE
WE ARE IN TERMS OF BUDGET.
BUT ALL THE REQUESTER ARE.
INTERESTING REQUEST VERY GOOD
REQUEST AND SOME OF THEM OVERLAP
EACH OTHER SO I I'M THINKING OF
WAYS IN WHICH THEY CAN PROBABLY
BE BUNDLED IN SOME WAY OF THAT.
EITHER SOMETHING THAT WERE
ALREADY FUNDING AND CAN ADD TO
THAT OR.
MAYBE IT AGENCY THAT SOMEONE IS
IDENTIFIED REALLY HANDLES ALL
THOSE THINGS OF SOME OF THE
REQUESTS ARE OVERLAPPING.
BUT THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE CONCERNS
OF CONCERN THAT WE ALL HAVE
SOARED ON BEGIN WITH YOU MISTER
ARAMBULA.
IF YOU'LL GIVE US SO.
FIVE MINUTES OF YOUR TIME TO
TELL US WHAT YOUR PROPOSALS ARE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY
REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S.
TAX RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE ALSO
KNOWN AS TRACE.
THE REQUEST FOR FUNDING IS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SENATE BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY TWO. AUTHORED BY
SENATOR GALGIANI PRO TEM ATKINS
AND MYSELF.
WHICH HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
ACCORDING TO THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER REPORT THE STATE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY COULD BE AS
LARGE AS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
IT IS THEREFORE ESTIMATED THAT
THE STATE'S LOSES EIGHT POINT
FIVE BILLION IN CORPORATE
PERSONAL AND SALES TAX EACH YEAR
AN AMOUNT THAT IS ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT TO THE STATE'S RAINY
DAY FUND.
BASED ON THESE NUMBERS THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT UNCOLLECTED REVENUES
THAT ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
FUND BASIC GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY MORE
THAN DOUBLED BETWEEN NINETEEN
SEVENTY IN TWO THOUSAND. MAKING
EXPANSIONS OF PROGRAMS TASK WITH
THE REIGNING IN THEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER.
A TRACE TASK FORCE HAS BEEN
OPERATING AS A PILOT PROGRAM
WITH TEAMS LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES AND HAS
RECOVERED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LOST TAX REVENUE. FOR THE STATE.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL EXPAND
TRACED TO THREE MORE LOCATIONS
INCLUDING SAN DIEGO FRESNO AND
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
PUBLISHER REPORT ON THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THAT
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
TASK FORCE AND RECOMMENDED THE
PROGRAM'S EXPANSION TO EVERY
METROPOLITAN REGION.
AS A RESULT I AM HERE TODAY.
TO REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
SUBCOMMITTEE CONSIDER ALLOCATING
THE TRACE TASK FORCE ELEVEN
POINT EIGHT SIX THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO BOLSTER THEIR EFFORTS IN
DISRUPTING THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
SO FAR THE TASK FORCE HAS
IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION IN UNREPORTED GROSS
RECEIPTS
AND FORTY SIX MILLION AND
ASSOCIATED TAX LOSSES TO THE
STATE.
ALMOST ANOTHER THIRTY MINUTES TO
DATE THE TASK FORCE HAS
RECOVERED OVER TEN MILLION
DOLLARS WITH ALMOST ANOTHER
THIRTY MILLION IN ANTICIPATED
BILLINGS AND RESTITUTION FOR TAX
LOSSES ASSOCIATED WITH ONGOING
CASES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
NEITHER TEAM HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
STAFFED WITH FULL TIME
PERSONNEL.
FULL TIME DEDICATED STAFFING AND
AN INCREASE IN DOJ AGENTS WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY IMPROVE RESULTS.
GIVEN THE PERSISTENT AND
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS EXCUSE ME
AFFECTS OF THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. FROM LABOR LAW
VIOLATIONS TO UNFAIR COMPETITION
TO LOST TAX REVENUE.
WE NEED BETTER ENFORCEMENT.
THEREFORE I AM REQUESTING THE
COMMITTEE APPROVE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE TRACE TASK FORCE IS DESIGNED
TO PROTECT HONEST HARDWORKING
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS.
INSURERS CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND ENJOYS A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT INCLUDING BOTH LABOR AND
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND CONSIDERATION ON
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IN HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MARIO DE
BERNARDO FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MARIO DIBERNARDO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVEA
BUT SARAH. WHO'S THE SPONSOR OF
S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY TWO WHICH
WOULD CODIFY AND STRENGTHEN THE
TAP THAT TREATS TASK FORCE TO
HELP. COMBAT THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA IS
BUDGET REQUEST WOULD FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO. SWEATS AS SUCH WE
SUPPORT. THIS REQUEST
ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HAS MADE WE THANK HIM FOR CO
AUTHORING ARE BILL AND MAKING
THIS REQUEST
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE.
TO SUPPORT THIS REQUEST.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY ANY
QUESTIONS.
NOW MY SENSES AS WE TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO IS STILL IN THE
SENATE.
BUT IT'S IT'S HASN'T BEEN PASSED
YET THAT'S WORK OKAY FINE
ALRIGHT.
.
OKAY IT QUESTIONS IN ONE HOUSE.
OKAY YET ANOTHER REQUEST YES MEN
WHO.
BEFORE YOU DO THAT LET ME GET A
QUORUM.
ROLL CALL.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY HERE MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THEY WILL GIVE THIS REQUEST AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE BOOK VOTE ITEMS IN CASE SOME
OF YOU HAVE TO.
GO OR WE HAVE TO TAKE A RECESS
SOMETHING
OKAY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WATER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
CONSIDERATION OF A GENERAL FUND
BUDGET APPROPRIATION IN THE
AMOUNT OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS.
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL
BE USED FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
FUNDING FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OR
RENOVATION OF LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT FACILITIES. AND SMALL
UNDERSERVED RURAL COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF THE EXISTING POLICE
FACILITIES IN SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES
AND CITIES DO NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
SPACE FOR PERSONNEL AND
EQUIPMENT.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR SPACE TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THE TO ME
ENTITIES IN WHICH THEY SERVE.
MANY LACK THE SPACE NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE TRAINING TO STORE
EVIDENCE TO CONDUCT BOOKINGS AND
OTHER SPACE IS REQUIRED BY THE
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING.
MANY WERE BUILT BEFORE NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND FACE SERIOUS SAFETY
CONCERNS.
THESE SUBSTANDARD POLICE
STATIONS ALSO DO NOT HAVE
PRIVATE INTERVIEW ROOMS OR SPACE
TOGETHER WITNESS REPORTS.
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES UTILIZE EVERY
AVAILABLE TOOL AND RESOURCE TO
DELIVER QUALITY PUBLIC SAFETY.
BUT THEY NEED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT THEY CAN
PERFORM THEIR JOBS SAFELY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE DESPERATE
NEED OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING A TOTAL OF EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY FACILITIES AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN.
A TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET INCLUDED JUST
OVER TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION AND RENOVATION OF
POLICE DEPARTMENT FACILITIES.
LAST YEAR THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
HEARD AND RECEIVED REQUEST FOR
FUNDING IN EXCESS OF THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ESTABLISH A
NEW COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE B. S.
CC.
TO BE ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE CITIES
MUST HAVE A POPULATION LESS THAN
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND.
THIRTY THOUSAND IN ADDITION AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
CITY CENSUS TRACKS.
MUST BE EITHER HAVE A MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD. INCOME AT OR BELOW
EIGHTY PERCENT
OF THE STATEWIDE MEDIAN INCOME
OR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION AS DETERMINED BY THE
CAL IN VIRAL SCREEN.
THIS PROGRAM WILL ESTABLISH A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WILL ALLOW THE BE SEC TO ASSESS
A CITIES NEED AND AWARD MONEY TO
THE LOCALITIES. THAT NEED IT THE
MOST.
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL COMMUNITIES
FACE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
MAINTAINING THE PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IF APPROVED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL HELP
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES MAKE
DESPERATELY NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS
TO THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY
FACILITIES.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
FOR THE SUPPORT AND WITH ME I
BROUGHT ROLANDO CASTRO MAYOR OF
MENDOTA AS WELL AS THEIR POLICE
CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND WHEELS MOST
WALDRON DODA.
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT NOW WE'VE
WE RAN WE DON'T OWN.
EAST TO BE AN OLD PACKING HOUSE
OFFICE WHICH THEY WE MODIFIED IT
INTO A PD. AND IT'S ON THE
OUTSIDE OF MENDOTA.
IT'S IT'S I WE WORK WE RECENTLY
PURCHASED A PIECE OF LAND CENTER
MENDOTA WHAT MY VISION OF
OPENING MY NEW CHOOSE HIS AND
I'M SORRY. HOPEFULLY IN BUILDING
THE PD THERE.
BEING THE CENTER OF TOWN IT'S
TWENTY FIVE MILES AWAY FROM MY
FIVE AND WE'VE HAD.
VIOLENT WORSE THINGS HAPPEN
PEOPLE ARE QUICK TO GO TO THE
FREEWAY AND GET AWAY. THAT WE
HAVE IN THE CENTER OF TOWN. I
THINK IT'LL BE KEEPER PAY
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFE PEOPLE THINK
TWICE OF DOING THINGS BECAUSE
THE PD. IT'S IN THE PRESENCE.
.
ALSO THAT WE HAD RECENTLY BUDGET
CUTS WE RECENT HOW TO CUT TWO
OFFICERS.
HOW WERE FRIEZA POSITIONS FOR
NOW I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN BUILD
THEIR OWN INFRASTRUCTURE
CALDERON P. D. WITH HOLDING
CELLS?
WITH THAT MONEY WE SAVE AROUND
WE CAN PROVIDE JOBS AGAIN OF
THOSE TWO OFFICES IN FREEDOM UP.
SO MUCH RENT WE PAY ALSO I WILL
HAVE TO OFFICERS PER SHIFT. SO
WE WE GOT IT DETAIN A.
THE YOU KNOW WHATEVER WILL WANT
ONE TO CRIMINALS WE GOT OF
TRIBAL FORTY FIVE MINUTES AWAY
IN OUR TOWN STAYS THE ONE
OFFICER. FOR THREE TO FOUR
HOURS.
SO I WANT TO KEEP MY COMMUNITY
SAFE AND I'M ASKING YOU TO
PLEASE HELP. THANK YOU CAN
DEFERRED ACHIEVE RIGHT ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MANY MEMBERS.
IT IN.
NOT HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE MARCO
FIRE STATION POLICE STATIONS ON.
A LOT OF THEM WERE BUILT.
BECAUSE.
UNREINFORCED MASONRY BUILDINGS
AND SO I. WOULD I WOULD HAVE
TOSSED THE THOUGHTFUL LOOK AT
THE THE INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF
THAT MAYBE YOU. AS PART OF A
REQUIREMENT THAT ADAM BUT THE
BUILDING HAS COME TO THE END OF
ITS USEFUL LIFE.
AND IN THAT MAY BE USED THESE
FUNDS TO ALSO.
AT THAT AS A PART OF THE
CRITERIA CLINTON LASTING YOU
WANT IS FOR AN EARTHQUAKE TO
HAPPEN AND IT FOR THE RIGHT HAND
CAKE.
ON TOP OF OF.
MY ONLY OFFICERS WENT TO PUT THE
PRISONERS THAT YEAR YOU'RE
HOLDING AND CITIZENS THAT MIGHT
BE IN THAT PLACE SO JUST A
SUGGESTION DOT TO HELP WITH WITH
THE BUT REQUEST I CAN SPEAK ON
THE NEIGHBOR LEAD CITIES WHO
HAVE REPEATED DEPARTMENT CATS
ARE PRETTY OLD. AND I VISIT HIM
THEY ARE DATE TO NEED TO LOOK
INTO THAT BUT AS FAR AS MEN
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE OUR OWN PD
CONSIDERABLY ON.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
REQUEST WILL WILL LOOK AT THAT
WE I THINK WE'VE DONE.
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO THIS BEFORE
I THINK.
AND FRESNO IN SOME OF THE
SURROUNDING AREA SO WE'LL LOOK
AT THE REQUEST OF ONE THANK YOU
GUYS FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
COME.
UP AND THANK MISTER ARAMBULA FOR
MAKING THE REQUEST THANK YOU AND
GOOD LUCK OR.
IN.
DO WE HAVE DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WANNA MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
EITHER ONE OF THESE ITEMS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
TOP OF THE AGENDA TO THE VOTE
ONLY ITEMS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
NOT ONLY IS THAT CORPS AND WE
CAN THOSE WITH A HERE SUPPOSED
TO PROBABLY GO TO OTHER MEETINGS
AS WELL. AND WILL CALL LET THOSE
WHO ABSENT VOTE LATER WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH A VOTE ONLY
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER STATE ACTIVE DUTY
COMPENSATION BROKAW.
WEBER.
I.
JONES SAWYER BY LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY AND THAT WAS THE POOL FOR
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS STATE
ACTIVE DUTY COMPENSATION FUND
THAT PASSES THREE ZERO BUT WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR.
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS THE SPRING OF FINANCE
LETTER AGAIN FOR THE BAKERSFIELD
SUSTAINABLE ARMORY RENOVATION
PROJECT.
BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE SAY THAT PASSES
WITHOUT THREE OH WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS A SPRING LETTER
FOR SAN QUENTIN STATE PRISON NEW
BORDER FACILITY BROKAW. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE YEAH THAT IS ALSO
OUT THREE OH WITH SO WE'LL HOPE
HOLD IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS WHO
ARE.
A ABSENT RIGHT NOW ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER CORRECTIONAL TRAINING
FACILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION CELL DOOR RETROFIT.
LOCAL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OKAY THAT TO PASS
IS A THREE OH WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. OF THE
COCHRAN LEVY ASSESSMENT OF.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ROCO.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE THAT'S UP
THREE OH ALSO ENABLED IT OPEN.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE DENTAL
EQUIPMENT.
BROKE OFF.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
YEAH THAT'S OUT THE REAL ALSO
OWN WILL HOLD IT OPEN BUT ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE DENTAL
ORAL SURGERY. ROLL CALL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE IF IT'S OUT THREE
OH.
WILL HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT ITS RECEIVER CORRECTIONAL
CLINIC MODEL PHARMACEUTICALS
BROKAW.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE.
MELENDEZ
STONE SAID THAT SOUTH THREE OLD
WILL HOLD OPEN THE LAST ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER NINE RECEIVER
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM
ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ
STONE OKAY ALTHOUGH I VOTE ONLY
ITEMS OUT TODAY ON THE THREE OH
VOTE WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
HOWEVER.
.
FOR I MEAN. FOR THOSE WHO ABSENT
SECOND PERSON WHO WANTS TO MAKE
A PRESENTATION CONCERNING THEIR
OF.
QUEST DOT THE WOULD. MAKE A
STATEMENT.
ALL CONCERNING LAW LIBRARIES
YES.
MR WOULD.
THINK ABOUT SHARON MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT A ONE
TIME SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
ALLOCATION FOR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES.
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES ARE
VALUABLE RESOURCE ESPECIALLY THE
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO AFFORD LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
BUT COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES ARE NOT
COUNTY AGENCIES THERE ARE NOT
FUNDED BY COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
THEY RECEIVE NO GENERALISED
BESSEL FUND APPROPRIATIONS FROM
THE STATE.
MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT OF
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY FUND FUNDING
COMES FROM A SMALL PORTION OF
THE CIVIL FILING FEES FROM TWO
DOLLARS.
THE FIFTY DOLLARS PER CASE
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY AND THE
TYPE OF THE CASE.
THE CIVIL FILING FEE REVENUE
THAT COUNTY LAW EVERITT
LIBRARIES DEPEND UPON HAS
DROPPED FORTY PERCENT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE TO TWO A
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER CASE
VIOLENCE.
COMBINED WITH AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF FEE WAIVERS GRANTED
AND NEW EXEMPTIONS ADOPTED INTO
LAW.
THIS ONE TIME ALLOCATION WOULD
ASSURE THAT COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
CAN REMAIN OPEN PROVIDING THE
TIME TO DETERMINE IN A POP UP ON
GOING FUTURE STABLE FUNDING.
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY TO HELP
ASSIST DISTRESS PARENTS FIGHTING
FOR CUSTODY OF THEIR CHILDREN
ADULT CHILDREN TIME TO NAVIGATE
THE CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS. TO
CARE FOR THEIR ELDERLY PARENTS
ENTREPRENEURS TRYING TO START
NEW BUSINESSES IMMIGRANTS
STRUGGLING WITH COMPLEX
APPLICATION FORMS.
PEOPLE TERRIFIED BY THREATS FROM
UNSCRUPULOUS BILL COLLECTORS
TENANTS LIVING IN DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS
IT'S SO MUCH MORE.
IT MY DISTRICT AFTER THE RECENT
WILDFIRES THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
LOST THEIR HOMES AND BUSINESSES
AND EMPLOYMENT. THE LAW
LIBRARIES HAVE PROVIDED VALUABLE
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE WHO WERE
WORKING THROUGH COMPLICATED
PAPERWORK. VARIOUS BUREAUCRACIES
THAT TRY TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
THE CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REPORTS AT SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF CIVIL CASES NASH CASES
NATIONALLY AND MORE THAN EIGHTY
PERCENT OF FAMILY LAW MATTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
BOB AT LEAST ONE SELF
REPRESENTED SELF REPRESENTED
LATE LITIGANT.
THE COST OF HIRING A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY IS SIMPLY PROHIBITED
FOR THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS.
LEGAL AID PRO BONO ORGANIZATIONS
AND COURT BASED SELF HELP
CENTERS DO WONDERFUL WORK. BUT
THEY CAN ONLY ADDRESS A SMALL
PORTION OF THE NEED.
THE COURTS ARE CLOGGED WITH
UNPREPARED SUFFER REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WHO WITHOUT SUPPORT
EDUCATION OFTEN DELAYED
PROCEEDINGS WASTE THE COURT'S
TIME FRUSTRATE COURT OFFICERS IN
ADD SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE COSTS
OF MEN OF ADMINISTERING JUSTICE.
LAW LIBRARIES CAN HELP PEOPLE
COME TO COURT PREPARE FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
THE FACTS YOU NEED THE FIRST
TIME.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IN THESE
CASES JUSTICE IS NOT WELL
SERVED.
JUST A JUDGES AND ATTORNEYS.
TELLS AT THE ABILITY OF COURSE
TO DELIVER JUSTICE IS COMPLETELY
UNDERMINED WHEN LITIGANTS
DO NOT KNOW HOW TO FOLLOW
PROCEDURE PRESENT A CASE SUBMIT
EVIDENCE.
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE MY MY
WERE MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
DEVON MATHIS HAS ALSO SUBMITTED
A LETTER REQUESTING THIS
FUNDING.
AND ALL AND ALTHOUGH HE COULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY YES I LET YOU
KNOW OF HIS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
IT COMES FROM MEMBERS.
QUICK QUESTION IF DO YOU YOU'VE
GOT.
IN ALLOCATION HERE IS A REQUEST
AS A ONE TIME REQUEST CRACKED
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE ONE TIME
WHICH TOOK THE THE LAW THAT LAW
LABOR SILICON FOR CAN. THE TIME
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH OF A
LONG TERM FUNDING SOURCE AND
THAT IS LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION
EXACT IS IT JUST A STOP GAP
MEASURES ACT WITH THE LAW. WHICH
LAW LIBRARIES ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE DO YOU.
I'M NOT SURE A YES WHICH GAUGE
COUNTY AT THIS COUNTY HAS A
LIBRARY BUT I MEAN I WAS HE SOME
MUST BE IN MORE NEED THAN OTHERS
PROBABLY THEY ARE AND.
YOU KNOW HOW THIS IS ALLOCATED
ONE HOME AT THIS POINT I'M AS
I'M I'M NOT I'M NOT SURE ABBY
CAN BITE US WITH YOU. BUT THIS.
AT I THINK THIS IS OF INTEREST
REQUEST IN WRITING DID IT VARIES
BASED ON POPULATION I KNOW MY
OWN COUNTY LOPPED LIBRARY AS A
CINEMA COUNTY AND SAW THE
RESOURCES YOU KNOW PLUMMET AND
DOUG. AND THE SERVICE NEED RISE
SO.
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A BRIDGE TO.
HOPEFULLY.
ALL OF THE TIME WE ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE FUNDING.
THE ONE I KNOW I KNOW WE HAVE.
.
WE JUST FUNDED WELL WE'RE
LOOKING AT FUNDING IN THE COURTS
OF THESE.
.
FOLKS WHO HELP PEOPLE FOR THAT.
IS THE SELF HELP CENTERS.
OF HOW DOES THIS DO YOU KNOW IF
THIS IN A PHASES AT ALL WITH THE
SELF HELP LET CENTERS THAT I
DON'T KNOW OKAY. ALRIGHT.
OKAY TO RE INTERESTING TO KNOW
OKAY BUT DON'T GET THAT
INFORMATION FOR A MANAGER AYE.
OKAY SO WE GET TO SEE IT IT
WOULD NOT THIS IS A PART OF THAT
OKAY.
DO HAVE ANY UP PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON THIS YES MADAM CHAIR MICHAEL
COR BET ONE. REPRESENTING THE
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIANS IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION THERE IS AN INTERFACE
BETWEEN COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
AND.
SELF HELP CENTERS IN SOME OF
THE COUNTIES NOT ALL OF THE
COUNTIES.
BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT TO
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS.
SERVE ROUGHLY A HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE PER YEAR.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THAT THE PROBLEM AROSE
WITH A UNIFORM CIVIL FILING FEE
WENT INTO EFFECT. IT TOOK AWAY
THE ABILITY OF COUNTY
SUPERVISORS TO RAISE THAT
PORTION OF THE CIVIL FILING FEES
THAT WENT TO COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES SO THERE HAVE BEEN FOR
INCREASES IN THE CIVIL FILING
FEE SINCE THAT LAW WENT INTO
EFFECT. BUT NONE OF THOSE FUNDS
WERE ALLOCATED TO COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES THEY ALL WENT TO THE
COURTS TO HELP BACK FILL FOR
GENERAL FUND CUTS.
I IS THERE ANY.
.
NOT TRUTH IS ANY VALUE IN
CONVERSATION WITH REGARDS TO
TECHNOLOGY IN TERMS OF IS THAT.
.
BUT YOU FIND MORE MORE FOLKS
USING TECHNOLOGY IN ACCESSING
THINGS IN THAT METHOD RATHER
THAN ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY GOING
TO LIVE WHERE WE. COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES SERVICE BOTH OF THOSE
NEEDS THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT
TECHNOLOGY ALONE WON'T HELP
THEM.
OF FILL OUT THE NECESSARY PAPERS
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
GOODLY NUMBER OF SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS GO TO
COURT IN THE PAPERWORK IS A
FLAWED.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
PAPERWORK IS FLAWED THAT
PARTICULAR CASES PUT OVER THE
COURTS WASTED TIME THAT DAY ON
THAT CASE. AND THAT.
STALLS THE WHOLE PROCESS OF OF
OF COURT OPERATIONS.
ISN'T IS VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES BE FUNDED
WE HAVE SOME LAW LIBRARIES THAT
ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF ACTUALLY
CLOSING.
THIS FORTY PERCENT AGGREGATE CUT
THAT HAS OCCURRED ACROSS THE
STATE HAS IMPACTED DIFFERENT
LIBRARIES IN DIFFERENT WAYS IN
TERMS OF THE. LEVEL OF LOS
FUNDING BUT ALL OF THEM HAVE
LOST FUNDING.
YOU VERY MUCH.
SLASH BUT
YEAH. WHERE?
HOW DO WE ARRIVE AT THE FIGURE
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION?
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION IS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES WRIST
RECEIVING WHEN THE UNIFORM CIVIL
FILING FEE WENT INTO EFFECT AND
THE LATEST YEAR FOR WHICH WE
HAVE NUMBERS WHICH IS TO. FISCAL
YEAR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
OKAY SO WHAT WOULD THERE BE SOME
KIND OF PLAN OF DISTRIBUTION YES
THE DISTRIBUTION WOULD BE THE
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE COVERS EVERY
LIE EVERY LIBRARY. BACK TO THE
POINT OF WHAT THEY RECEIVING IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
IQ LIKE YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR THE RECOMMENDATION POLITICAL
POST. OKAY
THAT BRINGS US TO.
A OVER MISTER OBERNOLTE YES
THE JUDGESHIPS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF.
REQUEST FOR SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND TEN ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS IN CALIFORNIA THIS
WOULD BE A VERY MODEST DOWN
PAYMENT ON THE CRITICAL LACK. OF
JUDGESHIPS IN THE STATE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DID A STUDY IN WHICH IT
IDENTIFIED THAT WE ARE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY JUDGES SHORT. OF
MEETING OF JUDICIAL WORKLOAD
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED.
THE GUY CREATION OF FIFTY
ADDITIONAL JUDGESHIPS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
RECESSION AT THAT TIME NONE OF
THOSE POSITIONS WERE FUNDED AND
SINCE THEN THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER. OF ATTEMPTS TO FUND
ADDITIONAL JUDGESHIPS IN
CALIFORNIA ALL OF WHICH HAVE
FAILED.
THE AND I WANT TO SHARE
SOMETHING FROM MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT MAKES IS A VERY
POIGNANT ISSUE FOR ME BEFORE
SERVING IN THIS LEGISLATURE I
WAS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF BIG
BEAR LAKE AND WHILE I WAS MAYOR.
WE HAD OUR COURTHOUSE IN BIG
BEAR CLOSED AND SO I GOT TO SEE
FIRSTHAND THE EFFECTS ON A
COMMUNITY WHEN DICK YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR RESIDENTS
LOSE ACCESS TO JUSTICE. AND IT
GAVE ME AN INCREDIBLY POIGNANT
APPRECIATION FOR THE FACT THAT
THE FUNDAMENTAL.
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNMENT IS
TO PROVIDE THAT ACCESS FOR
JUSTICE.
BUT WHEN I WAS ELECTED TO THIS
POSITION I CAME TO REALIZE THAT
WHEN OUR COURTHOUSE WAS CLOSED
ON THAT DAY WASN'T JUST OUR
COURTHOUSE BUT THERE WERE FIVE
COURT HOUSES MY DISTRICT THAT
WERE CLOSE THAT SAME DAY.
AND NOW I CAN TELL YOU THAT EVEN
OUR COURTHOUSE IN BIG BEAR IS
NOT THE MOST DIRE.
PRESENTATION OF THE PROBLEM WE
LOST ALSO THE COURTHOUSE IN
NEEDLES AND MY CONSTITUENTS
NEEDLES WHEN THEY NEED TO HAVE
SOMETHING EDUCATED ARE NOW
DRIVING THREE AND A HALF HOURS.
TO GET TO THE NEAREST
COURTHOUSE.
AND.
YOU COULD IMAGINE THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE THAT KIND OF REQUIREMENT TO
GET ACCESS TO JUSTICE. THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT LOSE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED. MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD TO TAKE THE WHOLE
DAY OFF OF WORK OR CAN'T AFFORD
SEVEN HOURS OF FUEL FOR THEIR
VEHICLE TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
COURT. SO I IT'S REALLY GIVEN ME
AN APPRECIATION FOR THIS NEED.
THE ABOUT THE WERE ASKING FOR
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS JUST
A VERY SMALL DOWN PAYMENT ON
SOLVING THAT PROBLEM. SO WITH ME
TO OF FURTHER TESTIFY ON HOW
DIRE THE SITUATION IS BECOME HIS
JUDGE VANDERVEER HE IS THE
PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE. US
AMADOR COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
NEEDLES IF YOU LIVE THERE AND
YOU DON'T HAVE A CAR.
TWO FRIDAYS A MONTH YOU CAN GET
ON A BUS AT SIX FIFTEEN IN THE
MORNING AND IF YOU'RE CASES IN
BARSTOW ITS TRAFFIC. GET DROPPED
THEIR IN THEM OFF THERE IN THE
MORNING.
IF YOUR CASE IS A MISDEMEANOR
YOU GO TO VICTORVILLE.
AND YOU GET HOME AT SEVEN
FIFTEEN PM SO IT'S A THIRTEEN
HOUR DAYS FOR BECAUSE YOU MISSED
YOUR CLASSES DO I CLASS AND YOU
GOT IT REINSTATED ON PROBATION.
OUR QUOTAS RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE
MADE SOME CHANGES WERE YOU DOING
VIZIO REMOTE AT THE TIME BUT IT
STILL THERE'S TO STILL THE
STAFFING OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
THE CURRENT CASELOAD AVERAGE
CASELOAD FOR JUDGE ARE COUNTY
HAVING HANDLING CRIMINALS SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY PLUS AVERAGE
ACTIVE CASELOAD.
IN JUVENILE DEPENDENCY WE HAVE A
FIFTY TO PIT PERCENT INCREASE IN
FILINGS FROM FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE.
WAIT TIMES IN FAMILY LAW MAY
EXCEED TWO MONTHS TO GET ON THE
COUNTER UNLESS IT'S AN EMERGENCY
HEARING.
AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TIME A
COLLABORATIVE COURTS ARE DRUG
COURTS A VETERANS COURTS ARE
HOMELESS COURTS A MENTAL HEALTH
COURT CERTAIN OTHER CLUB IF
COURTS.
THOSE ARE TIME INTENSIVE COURTS
YOU NEED TO INTERACT AS A JUDGE
WITH THOSE APPEARING FRONT OF
YOU JUST CAN'T PUSH THE CASE
THROUGH AND CALL THE NEXT ONE
YOU NEED TO TAKES TIME WITH
THOSE PEOPLE.
.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET IS GREAT FOR THE
JUDICIARY WE ARE.
PORT ABOVE IT GIVES US THE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO DO A LOT.
BUT WHAT IT GIVES US IS MONEY WE
CAN USE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
GIVE US TIME.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT TIME TIME
TO THE LITIGANTS WHO DRIVE THREE
HOURS FIVE HOURS TO COURT THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HEARD
BECAUSE THERE'S ENOUGH. JUDGES
THERE TO HEAR ALL THE CASES THAT
ARE COUNTER THAT DAY.
TIME TO BE PRESENT THEIR CASE.
NOT FILLING THERE'S A ROOM FULL
OF PEOPLE.
I'VE KNOWN THE PAST RIGHT DONE
THIS TO MEET ARRAIGNMENTS I'VE
HAD TWO HUNDRED CASES ON IN
VICTORVILLE IN THE MORNING.
AND PEOPLE LOOK AROUND WHAT AND
HOW MUCH TIME I GOING TO GET YOU
GIVE THEM AS MUCH AS YOU CAN BUT
YOU HAVE TO GET THROUGH THE DAY.
SO WE ARE SUPPORT.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT GIVES IT
THAT LITIGANTS TIME BECAUSE THE
COURTS TIME AND IT IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
TO UNFULFILLED NEED IN THE
CALIFORNIA COURT SYSTEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. UP ANY ONE
IN THE AUDIENCE.
ONE IS JUST.
LET US KNOW THAT YOU'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF IT JUST YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AGENCY HOME CERTAINLY
MADAM CHAIR I'M ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE. A WHERE THE
NEED OF FOR JUDGESHIPS IS ALSO
WELL DOCUMENTED AND QUITE
CRITICAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY.
.
WE WILL LOOK INTO THIS WEEK WHEN
I YOU MAY KNOW WHAT WE ARE. I
THINK OUR PROPOSAL IS TO WHAT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. FOR
DISCRETION TO THE COURTS
TO USE AS THEY SEE FIT HOPEFULLY
TO REDUCE THE WAIT TIME AND. AN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
AND WE HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T PUT
NECESSARY OURSELVES IN A LIMIT
ON WHAT THAT MONEY COULD BE USED
FOR NO WE HAVE PUT IN SOME
LANGUAGES TRYING TO LOOK BECAUSE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BASICALLY
SAY IT SHOULD BE DESIGNED TO
REDUCE THE.
THE WORKLOAD WHICH WHICH WOULD
MAKE INVOLVE JUDGES MAY INVOLVE
CLERKS MAYBE IT WAS SO FAR DOWN
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS. IN
TERMS OF THAT BUT I THINK
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN FIVE
MILLION. FOR DISCRETION.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THAT DISCRETION SHOULD
BE TARGETED TOWARD.
JUDGESHIPS OR SOME OTHERS I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO TALK WITH YOU.
WORK THERE THOUGH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WITH REGARDS TO THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. AND WHAT
WOULD BE INCLUDED WHAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATED OF THE SEVEN FIVE
MILLION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE.
THAT'S BEEN DECIDED AT THIS TIME
MOCHA THAT BUT THAT.
I THINK THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUDGET AND THIS BILL AT BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING AT USING THAT
MONEY TO INVEST LIKE VIDEO
EQUIPMENT.
AND NEEDLES WE HAVE A VIDEO
REMOTE SO THAT MEASURE BAR SO
PEOPLE HAVE TO COME NOW BIO.
THAT TAKES TIME AND MONEY TO GET
BY THAT EQUIPMENT SET UP TO RUN
THE COURTHOUSE SO THAT IS
SEPARATE AND AND ARGUE.
FROM THIS BILL OVER WE NEED THE
JUDGES ARE HOME JUDGESHIPS
JUDICIAL OFFICERS.
.
AND THIS IS THE WAY TO GET THEM
THERE OKAY.
.
THIS THIS REQUEST OF THE FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THE.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON THE WOULD
ALLOCATED BASED ON NEEDS IT IS
WHAT IS THAT THE REQUEST THAT IT
THERE'S A THAT WOULD FUND TEN OF
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY POSITIONS I
SAY THEY NEED. A TEN OF THE
FIFTY ADDITIONAL JUDGES THAT
WERE AUTHORIZED WAY BACK.
ELEVEN YEARS AGO TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND THEY WOULD ALLOCATE
THOSE JUDGES ACCORDING TO A
METHODOLOGY CALLED THE WORKLOAD
ALLOCATION FORMULA SO THEY WOULD
GO TO.
WHATEVER COURT SYSTEMS HAD THE
HIGHEST JUDICIAL NEED.
ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE SHOULD.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO BAKER.
A I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S HERE.
SHE'S ON HER WAY THEN THAT'S
CABALLERO WHO'S NEXT.
THE BIGGER ISSUES HERE HOW.
HELLO I ASSUME YOU KNOW THAT
THERE TO REQUEST FOR THIS YES
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD. HOME WE WERE
GONNA DO IT TOGETHER BUT I THINK
THAT TIME CONSTRAINTS WORK SO
THAT. WE'RE DOING IT SEPARATELY
ALRIGHT NO PROBLEM.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BUDGET REQUEST TO
INVEST IN ONE OF THE STATE'S
MOST VITAL. LOCAL PROGRAMS IT
REDUCES CRIME AND VIOLENCE AND.
WAS GONNA. THINK THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN JONES SAWYER FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS LAST YEAR BUT HE'S
GONE.
SO I'LL MOVE ON THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION GRAT GRANT PROGRAM
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS CAL BE
IP IS CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
DEDICATED SOURCE OF STATE
SUPPORT FOR LOCALLY DRIVEN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION INITIATIVES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY TO HELP CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO IMPLEMENT
LIFESAVING CAUSTIC HAS AFFECTED
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE VIOLENCE.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM HAS PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE.
IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH THE
HELP OF CAL GRANT FUNDING THEIR
PREDECESSOR DEKALB VIP.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
WITNESSED A THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
REDUCTION IN HOMICIDES AND A
FORTY SIX PERCENT REDUCTION IN
AGGREGATE AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS.
THE CITY OF OAKLAND HAS SEEN A
FORTY THREE PERCENT DROP IN
HOMICIDES AND A FORTY NINE
PERCENT REDUCTION IN NON FATAL
INJURY SHOOTINGS SENSE IT'S
PROGRAM INCEPTION IN TWENTY.
TWELVE.
LAST YEAR OAKLAND EXPERIENCED
ITS LOWEST NUMBER OF HOMICIDES
IN TWENTY YEARS.
THE CITY OF SEASIDE WHICH WAS
AWARDED ONE POINT THREE MILLION
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD HAS ALL
ALSO EXPERIENCED A DRAMATIC DROP
IN HOMICIDES AND SHOOTINGS.
THE FUNDS PROVIDED TO THE CITY
OF SALINAS WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT HOPE TO IMPLY COMMUNITY
POLICE AND TWO OF SIT THE
CITY'S.
MOST TROUBLED NEIGHBORHOODS AND.
.
AND AND TO EXPAND ITS SATURDAY
NIGHT RECREATIONAL PROGRAM FOR
TEENS AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THESE EFFORTS THERE'S BEEN A
DRAMATIC DECLINING GANG AND
YOUTH VIOLENCE.
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE CONSIDER
THE FOLLOWING.
REAUTHORIZE KALBE IP PROGRAM AND
APPROPRIATE EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
THIS AMOUNT WOULD DOUBLE THE
FUNDING LEVEL FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR AND ALLOW MORE COMMUNITIES
TO PARTICIPATE. THIS YEAR THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS FROM OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY CITIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BUT THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN APPROPRIATION
WILL FIND ONLY TWENTY OF THOSE
LOCAL PROGRAMS.
THIS REQUEST WOULD ALLOW THE
BOARD.
TO AWARD MULTI YEAR GRANTS TO
AT LEAST TWENTY MORE CITIES AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
TO MAKE SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS
IN A NUMBER OF HIGH NEED
LOCALITIES.
SECONDLY IT WOULD ENSURE A
STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM BY CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATING FUNDS THROUGH THE
BUDGET ACT. THIS WOULD NOT ONLY
HOPE TO SUSTAIN SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EFFECTIVELY
REDUCING VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT PROVIDE GREATER
PREDICTABILITY FOR LOCAL
PLANNING PURPOSES.
AND THIRDLY.
UP THIS BUT ADOPTING BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE TO GIVE
PREFERENCE TO APPLICANTS
APPLICANTS.
THAT INCORPORATE A REGIONAL
APPROACH
TO REDUCING VIOLENCE THERE
THEREBY INCENTIVIZING MULTIPLE
CITIES AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO JOINTLY APART
APPLY FOR PROGRAM FUNDING IN MY
REGION THEIR NUMBER A VERY SMALL
COMMUNITIES THAT. ARE ARE ALL IN
RURAL AREAS THAT.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO COORDINATE
AND TO WORK TOGETHER TO BE ABLE
TO REDUCE VIOLENCE IN THIS WOULD
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO. SCORE I BELIEVE UP HIGHER
AND FINALLY PROVIDE THAT TEN
PERCENT OF AVAILABLE GRANT
FUNDING BE AWARDED TO
APPLICANTS.
FROM COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY GANG VIOLENCE AND
HAVE A STATE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY LOCATED IN THEIR
COUNTY.
ACCORDING TO THE DISEASE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE.
AND CONTROL CALIFORNIA GUN
RELATED HOMICIDE IS THAT BY
EIGHTEEN PERCENT REVERSING YEARS
OF DECLINE.
THE COST OF INNOVATIVE EFFECTIVE
EFFECTIVE VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
PROGRAM TO SMALL WHEN COMPARED
TO THE ENORMOUS COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE.
AND FRANKLY.
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON UP
LOOKING AT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR PRISON POPULATION BY
ALSO INVESTING IN PREVENTION
IT'S IT'S IT'S A WISE.
COMMUNITY BASED PREVENTION
STRATEGIES ON ARE REALLY CENTRAL
TO REALLY MAKING A DIFFERENCE
AND SO WITH ME HERE TODAY. AT
SPEAK BRIEFLY IT'S PART OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST IS MIKE MICHAEL I
BELIEVE FROM THE CUT GIFFORD'S
LAW CENTER TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND REMAINING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
DIFFERENT LAW CENTER WE ARE
ABOUT THE NATIONAL VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION AND WE
ARE BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW. I'M ALSO
PART OF A LARGER COALITION OF
MORE THAN THIRTY VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
GROUPS THAT ARE VERY INTERESTED
IN IN SUPPORTING AND MAINTAINING
FUNDING FOR CAL VIP.
.
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW IN THE
WAKE OF THE PARKLAND SHOOTING.
OUR ENTIRE NATION IS LOOKING
FOR SOLUTIONS TO GUN VIOLENCE AS
WE SHOULD BE AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE
NATION'S STRONGEST GUN LAWS BUT
WHERE WE FALL BEHIND SOME OF OUR
PEERS INCLUDING NEW YORK
MASSACHUSETTS AND CONNECTICUT.
IS THAT WE ARE NOT INVESTING AS
STRONGLY AS WE COULD BE IN
EVIDENCE BASED AND COMMUNITY
DRIVEN INTERVENTION PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS SERIOUS VIOLENCE. SO WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE A GUN VIOLENCE
PROBLEM IN THE STATE MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE ARE
KILLED EACH YEAR BY FIREARMS
ANOTHER FOUR THOUSAND ARE NON
FATALLY INJURED. AND MOST OF THE
SHOOTINGS ARE CONCENTRATED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT THOSE FOR THOSE
SHOOTINGS BOTH FAILING ON FETAL
CREATE AN ENORMOUS COST FOR OUR
STATE THAT WE ESTIMATE MORE THAN
SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
IN COST GENERATED HEALTHCARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT COSTS LOST WAGES
ETCETERA.
AND IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO
INVEST TO REDUCE THEIR SHOOTING.
DOT THE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE TALKING ABOUT ARE ALL BASED
ON THE PREMISE THAT A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE DRIVE MO
SHOOTINGS. IN OUR CITIES AND BY
INTERVENING IN A TIMELY AND
EVIDENCE BASED WAY WE CAN SEE
VERY RAPID REDUCTIONS IN
SHOOTINGS THAT YOU ALREADY HEARD
CITIES LIKE LA. OAKLAND IN
RICHMOND WHICH HAVE RECEIVED
SUPPORT FROM THIS PROGRAM OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE HAD
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO BUILD ON THAT BY
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. TAKES IF YOU SOMEWHAT
FOURTH YEAH I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE
THAT AS PART OF THE EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE OF CAL VIP
WHERE I SET WE JUST ISSUED OUR
LAST THAT OF OF OUR S. B. IS
LAST WEEK. MORE THAN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY CITIES AND CBO'S WERE
APPLYING FOR THIS FUNDING WE CAN
ONLY GIVE. THAT TWENTY GRANTS
THERE ANOTHER TWENTY
APPLICATIONS THAT RECEIVED VERY
HIGH SCORES INCLUDING
COMMUNITIES IN SALINAS
BAKERSFIELD LONG BEACH IN FRESNO
ALL AREAS WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
GUN VIOLENCE. THAT COULD NOT
RECEIVE GRANTS SIMPLY BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH FUNDING SO
WE THINK IT'S HIGH TIME THAT OUR
STATE COMBINED ARE STRONG GUN
LAWS WITH A VERY STRONG AND
STRATEGIC INVESTMENT IN THE
STRATEGIES THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
A.
.
YOU ARE CURRENTLY BEING FUNDED
SO THE FUNDING GOES UNTIL WHEN
AT THAT THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW WHEN THE FUNDING ENDS
RIGHT NOW THE CURRENT GRANT
WHICH JUST WAS ISSUED LAST WEEK
WILL GO FOR TWO YEARS SOCA.
BUT IT'S JUST FOR NINE MILLION
SO EACH TO EACH COMMUNITY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH
THE MOST THE COMMUNITY CAN GET
SO ESSENTIALLY THEY'RE GETTING
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
FOR PER YEAR FOR TWO YEARS AND
THEN THAT WILL RUN OUT FOR THE
NINE MILLION IS FOR TWO YEARS
AND SO THIS REQUEST IS TO BEGIN.
VISIT DOUBLE IT ARE AND TO BEGIN
IT.
FORT IN TWO YEARS OR SO THE SAME
YOU THIS YEAR COULD BE THE SAME
YEAR THIS YEAR ISSUE OKAY
ALRIGHT OKAY.
ANY ANY COMMENTS FROM ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE.
PLEASE JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AGENCY REPRESENTED WHETHER YOU
FOR OPPOSED OR. A FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAURIE JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF SALINAS
SEASIDE IN WATSONVILLE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN FRANCO.
I WORK FOR ORGANIZATION CALLED
ME BY THE ACRONYM STANDS FOR
MOTIVATED INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP
REPUBLIC ADVANCEMENT WORK IN
ORGANIZING A. NONPROFIT AND I
WORK REGIONALLY AND A LOT OF THE
CITIES AND I JUST SEE THE
COLLABORATION IS GOING ON WITH
THE COMMUNITY AND ALL THE
AGENCIES COMING TOGETHER. SO AN
INCREASE OF FUNDS IS IS WITH
DESIRE I'M A STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS A BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY I
ASSUME I DON'T HAVE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS AND EVERYONE ELSE MUST
NOT TO THE LEFT ME OVER.
SO ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THINK ABOUT A FEW THINGS YOU
THAT YOUR TANK OKAY.
WOULD BACK TO BURKE A BAKER
EXCUSE ME BAKER.
WHO?
IS HERE NOW INSERTING VERTICAL
PROSECUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I RUN
FAST FROM ONE COMMUNITY TO
ANOTHER ADULT AT. ALL WALDRON
FASTER NEXT TIME.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SO I
BIPARTISAN BUDGET REQUEST FOR
FUNDING FOR FEAR OF VERTICAL
PROSECUTION. OF CRIMINAL CASES
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE KNOW HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS.
CERTAINLY IT IS A MODERN DAY
SLAVERY BUT IT'S ALSO THE
FASTEST GROWING CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND EVERY YEAR THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE TRAFFIC JUST INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
AS THIS CRIME CONTINUES TO GROW
IN MY A DISTRICT ALONE JUST IN
MY FIRST TWO YEARS THREE. OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING RINGS ARE
BROKEN UP INCLUDING ONE OF THE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY AND THOSE
WERE JUST AND SMALL TOWN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THE FBI HAS THREE CAL HAS
FOUND THE CALIFORNIA HAS THREE
OF THE FBI'S TOP TEN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOT SPOTS OF FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
AND VERTICAL PROSECUTION IS ONE
OF THE MANY EFFECTIVE TOOLS THAT
WE CAN HAVE
A FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING WOULD
VERTICAL PROSECUTION IS IT MEANS
THAT WHEN THE CASE IS BEING
PROSECUTED THERE'S WENDY A FROM
THE START OF THE CASE. ALL THE
WAY TO THE VERY END INSTEAD OF
THE NEW DA AT EVERY STAGE OF
THAT CASE.
THERE'S MULTIPLE BENEFITS FROM
THIS FIRST AND FOREMOST IT'S A
VICTIM CENTERED FORM OF
PROSECUTION VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES ARE
TRAUMATIZED A THEY TEND HAVE
MANY OF THE SAME QUALITIES THAT
A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SPELLS ABUSE HAS. AND.
IT TAKES AWHILE TO COOPERATE
WITH AN ATTORNEY WITH STANDARD
PROSECUTION THEY HAVE TO. RE
ESTABLISH A RELATIONSHIP WITH A
NEW PERSON EACH TIME AND THAT
MAKES IT NOT ONLY DIFFICULT FOR
THE VICTIM BUT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE THE CASES
AND THEY END UP EITHER I'M
PROSECUTED OR. OFTEN PLAYED DOWN
TO LESSER CRIMES
AND.
IN ADDITION THE DA'S WHO ARE
WORKING IN VERTICAL PROSECUTION
SYSTEMS ARE ABLE TO GET VERY
GOOD AT THOSE CASES THAT ARE
QUITE COMPLEX.
AND SO WE'VE SEEN THE SUCCESS OF
THESE PROGRAMS I IN OTHER PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING ALAMEDA
COUNTY. WHICH IS ONE OF THE
LEADING AT COUNTIES IN THE STATE
FOR PROSECUTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES AND ALSO.
ALLOWING VICTIMS TO GO FORWARD
WITH THEIR LIVES TO BEGIN TO
REBUILD THEM.
I I WILL SAY THAT THIS IS A
PARTICULARLY NEEDED FUNDING NOW
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS DISCONTINUING ITS GRANTS TO
STATES UP TO FIGHT VERTICAL BUT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THROUGH
VERTICAL PROSECUTION IT'S REALLY
TIME FOR US TO STEP UP. AND SO I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND WITH
ME TODAY SHAUN HOFFMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'M.
THESE VERBAL PROSECUTION UNITS
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER.
SPOKE TO.
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT WE'RE
DEALING WITH VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING
IT CLEARLY YOUNG VICTIMS.
WERE VERY VULNERABLE AND
CREATING THAT STRUCTURE IN WHICH
WERE ABLE TO DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST BETWEEN
THE VICTIM THE PROSECUTORS
PROVEN TO BE. A VERY EFFECTIVE
METHOD OF PROSECUTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE COUNTIES THAT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO SO.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY IS IS
ONE OF THE. EXPERTS ON ON THE
ISSUE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE
NATION. THEY'VE A RESEARCH
INSTITUTE THAT IS LOOKED AT THE
TRAUMA SUFFERED BY VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ONE OF THE COMMONALITIES THAT
THEY'VE FOUND IN TALKING TO OVER
TO OVER A HUNDRED SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IS THAT
PARTICULARLY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN BEEN TRAFFICKED.
IS THAT MANY OF THEY HAVE MANY
LAYERS OF TRAUMA.
STARTING IN EARLY CHILDHOOD MANY
OF THEM EXPERIENCE HOME LIFE
THAT'S NOT SAFE THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED SEXUAL ASSAULT
SEXUAL ABUSE MEN ON INTO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID IS. REALLY
MODERN DAY SLAVERY ME SURVIVORS
OF SPOKE AT LENGTH ABOUT THE
LACK OF STABILITY OR CONSISTENCY
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES MAY BE
MOVING FROM ONE FOSTER HOME TO
ANOTHER FOSTER HOME. FROM ONE
SOCIAL WORKER TO ANOTHER SOCIAL
WORKER THAT SORT OF CONSTANT
CHANGING CHAOS REALLY BREEDS THE
VULNERABILITY THAT TRAFFICKERS
PREY ON.
AND SO THEIR EXPERIENCE HAVING
PROSECUTED ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS
IS THE REVERSE VERTICAL
PROSECUTION MODEL ISN'T HELPFUL
JUST IN TERMS OF BRINGING THESE
TRAFFICKERS TO JUSTICE. BUT IN
BEGINNING TO REPAIR.
THAT VICTIM AND BRING SOME
STABILITY TO THEIR LIVES WHICH
LAST LONG BEYOND THE OUTCOME
TRIAL SO.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BEING A
PROBLEM OBVIOUSLY IN IN SOME OF
THE LARGER MORE WELL RESOURCE
COUNTIES.
IS ALSO A PROBLEM IN A LOT OF
SMALLER COUNTIES TOWNS DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHICH IS WHY
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS SO
CRITICAL SO. UP WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME ASK YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE.
WAS GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AGENCY REPRESENT IN THE POSITION
THAT YOU TAKE ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DON CAP
KEY ON BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS VERTICAL
PROSECUTION CURRENTLY EXIST IN
SOME AREAS IRAQ TO. AND.
SO.
WHAT WHAT THE DISH NO RESOURCES
ARE NECESSARY TO TO?
TO IMPLEMENT I ME.
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT.
THAT THOSE OFFICES THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE A VERY WHOEVER
COULD ACTUALLY DO THIS ALREADY I
ASSUME. OF
SO WHY WOULD WE FUNDING
SOMETHING THEY CAN ALREADY DO
BUDGET TWO PARTS TO THAT AND
CERTAINLY WELCOME MAT MISTER
HOFFMAN'S IF THE FIRST IS THAT
AT THIS BODY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
THROUGH A HEARINGS FOUND THAT.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO FIND VERTICAL
PROSECUTION AND JUSTIN NINE TO
ELEVEN COUNTIES THAT DID NOT
HAVE THE FUNDING TO COMMIT TO
THOSE PARTICULAR.
STYLE OF OF PROSECUTION THAT WE
COULD MAKE GREAT HEADWAY IN
THOSE COUNTIES WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES BUT IT WAS THE
BUDGET.
HELP THAT THEY NEEDED IN ORDER
CASES THEY TAKE MORE RESOURCES.
AND AS IN ANY CASE WHEN WE'RE
FINDING THAT WE HAVE A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM WITH A FAST
GROWING CRIME IN OUR AREA WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE MAKING THE
INVESTMENT OF RESOURCES TO DO
IT.
AND SO IT'S TO BE PARTNERS AT
THE STATE LEVEL AYE WITH RDA
OFFICES ALSO REALIZING THAT THE
STATE.
PEOPLE ARE TRAFFICKED ACROSS
COUNTY LINES
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THIS SHOULD BE A STATE PRIORITY
MYSELF AND PROPS MISTER HOFFMAN
CAN ALSO ADD TO THAT. SURE I
WOULD HAVE SEEN IN SOME OF THE
LARGER OFFICES WHERE WE DO SEE
THESE VERTICAL PROSECUTION
UNITS.
THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF ATTORNEYS
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO KIND OF.
SILO THEM INTO PARTICULAR AREAS
OF EXPERTISE YOU GET INTO
SMALLER COUNTIES WERE YOU
TALKING ABOUT MAYBE HAVING.
EIGHT OR NINE PROSECUTORS IN
THAT OFFICE THERE CAN HANDLING
EVERYTHING THEY'RE HANDLING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THEY'RE
HANDLING. A YOU KNOW A ROBBERY
THEIR HANDLING.
.
DRUG SALES THERE IF THEY'RE
HANDLING KIND OF EVERYTHING THAT
THAT COMES IN THERE AND SO.
THEY'D THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO SAY OKAY THIS
PROSECUTOR IS HANDLING ALL OF
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES AND
THAT IS. THE ONLY THING THEY'RE
HANDLING SO THEY'RE DEVELOPING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WITH THE
VICTIMS THEIR DEVELOPING THE
EXPERTISE WITH THAT PARTICULAR
TYPE OF OFFENSE.
.
THESE GRANT FUNDS WOULD BE ABLE
TO.
IDEALLY PLACE A PROSECUTOR
DEDICATED TO THAT PARTICULAR
OFFENSE IN THOSE PARTICULAR
VICTIMS IN THESE OFFICES WHERE
RIGHT NOW. THEY'RE REALLY KIND
OF DEALING WITH WHATEVER COMES
UP AS IT COMES NAY DON'T HAVE
THAT.
.
THAT THAT LEVEL OF EXPERTISE TO
TO DEAL WITH THAT.
WHY IS WHAT AND I ASK THAT THINK
EARLIER WHITES IT WITH OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES?
OH YES ARE THEY ARE THE THE PAST
HEREDITY FOR A LOT OF OUR
FEDERAL GRANTS THAT WE GET
THROUGH THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
.
PERHAPS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COULD SPEAK TO WHY THEY'VE BEEN
CHOSEN FOR THIS PARTICULAR ONE
BUT WE DO RECEIVE A LOT OF GRANT
FUNDING. THROUGH OH YES IT'S
PRETTY WELL NOT TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL.
LET'S NOT TRY TO RE INVENT A
WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AND
FAMILIARITY WITH OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR HOW TO MANAGE
THOSE GRANTS AND LOOK AT THE
APPLICATIONS LIKE WHAT TO DO.
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THE DOLLARS
GO AS FAR AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN
AND BUILDING ON THAT KNOWLEDGE
OF RESOURCES WE'VE ALREADY
CULTIVATED IN THE STATUS
IMPORTANT TO DO. FOCA.
ALRIGHT.
THE GOING TO THE COURSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT
THANK YOU.
WELL THAT BRINGS US TO COURTS SO
WHAT.
STARBASE.
EVERYBODY.
THANK A MATTER MADAM CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS.
UP WHAT WE'RE HERE TO PRESENT
AND ASK FOR A ONE TIME BUDGET
ASK OF ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO EXPAND THE
STARBASE. YOUTH PROGRAM AT THE
JOINT FORCES TRAINING BASE AND
LOOKS ALAMEDA THOSE.
I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO GO VISIT
THE STARBASE PROGRAM THIS LAST
SUMMER ALONG WITH SPEAK IT
SPEAKER UP RENDON AND WHAT WE
SAW THERE.
WAS A REALLY ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK WE SEE AN EDUCATION
AS BEST PRACTICES WHICH WERE
WERE STUDENTS THAT WERE NOT ONLY
ENGAGED BUT WERE ACTIVE WERE
MOVING AROUND FROM STATION TO
STATION. VERY QUALIFIED TEACHING
STAFF WITH TEACHERS WITH
CREDENTIALS ARE AGAIN SET IT SET
THE SETTING OUT TO LOS ALAMOS ME
NO SOME. OF LOS ELEMENTOS
MILITARY BASE.
FOR SOME OF YOU WHO MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN IN THE CLASSROOM AND A
WHILE I WE ALWAYS KNOW THAT WHEN
STUDENTS HAVE THE CHANCE TO GET
OFF CAMPUS INTO ANOTHER SETTING
THIS ALSO INCREASES THE
LEARNING.
FOR THEM THIS IS ALL SO BRING
STUDENTS IN NOT ONLY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY BUT FROM LOS ANGELES AND
BRITNEY DO YOU KNOW RIVERSIDE
AND SAN DIEGO. COUNTIES IT'S A
PROGRAM WHERE STUDENTS COME FOR
FIVE DAYS A WEEK UP THEY DO NOT
SPEND THE NIGHT.
BUT THEY ARE THERE FIVE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS AYE IT THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT IS UP PAID FOR
WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PAYS FOR
ALL OPERATING COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH STARBASE. AND THE STATE.
WOULD THEN THAT MATCHING PART
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE THE
CLASSROOM SO THIS BUDGET OFGEM
AUGMENTATION WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW A THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT BUILDING. AND WITH THAT TO
A WE HAVE A COLONEL DARREL
DARREN VENDOR HERE.
.
THE SHOW IS SUPPORT OKAY.
HI MADAM CHAIR A I'M DARYN
BENDER I WORK WITH A CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT THIS IS NOT.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT. BUT I CAN.
SPECIFIED TO SOME
FACTS AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
AND SO THE ONLY.
BACKS THAT ALL SPECIFIED TO YOU
ARE HOW WE.
JUDGE.
EXCESS IN OUR STARBASE PROGRAM.
WE JUST LIKE JUDGE SUCCESS BASED
ON TEST SCORES THAT WE TEST THE
STUDENTS.
WHEN THEY COME IN AND THEN WE
TESTED WHEN THEY COME OUT AND
THE AVERAGE SCORE GOES FROM.
OUT OF A HUNDRED FROM A FIFTY
FOUR ON AVERAGE TO A TO A
NINETY.
IN TERMS OF A MATCH A SCIENCE
SKILLS AND STEM SKILLS. WE ALSO
JUDGE THE PROGRAM'S SUCCESS
BASED ON DEMAND INCREASING
DEMAND AND THEY'RE SO MUCH
DEMAND NOW THAT WE HAVE TO SAY
NO TO FORTY SIX SCHOOLS. IN
THOSE COUNTIES THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA MENTIONED.
THAT'S ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE BUT CAN'T SO THIS.
A NEW FACILITY THIS NEW
CLASSROOM WILL ALLOW THAT THIS
FEDERAL PROGRAM TO EXPAND TO
INCLUDE ALL FORTY SIX OF THOSE
CLASSES THAT ARE ON THE WAIT
LIST.
AND THIS IS.
THAT THIS. YOUNG PEOPLE SPENT A
WEEK AT THIS PLACE IS THAT
CORRECT YES MA'AM OKAY AND SO
THE FUNDING THE FUNDING FOR THAT
KIND OF PROGRAM IS DONE THROUGH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THAT
CORRECT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PAYS FOR THE TEACHERS AND FOR
ALL OF THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND
ALL THE. EQUIPMENT THEY HAVE
THREE D. PRINTERS THEY HAVE
SIMULATION SOFTWARE THE UPROOTED
MATT.
PROTOTYPING SOFTWARE ALL KINDS
OF REALLY HIGH TECH GADGETS ALL
PAID FOR BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOES THIS BUDGET
ALLOCATION IS DESIGNED FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF FACILITY.
FOR ONE CLASSROOM YASSIN A
MILLION ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO BILL AND FUND THE
SCHOOLS RESPONSIBILITY AS FOR
THE TRANSPORTATION AND I KNOW
THAT SEVERAL OF THEM ARE ABLE TO
ALSO. APPLY FOR GRANTS WITHIN
THEIR DISTRICTS BUT YES IT'S ONE
ONE.
IF IT'S A PORTABLE TOILETS THAT
SET SO WE HAVE A.
.
TRAINING BASE IN LOS ALAMEDA IS
THAT ALREADY HAS AN EXISTING
STARBASE CLASSROOMS OF THIS
WOULD BE AN EXACT DUPLICATE.
BUILT RIGHT NEXT TO IT
SO THAT THE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
COMBINED SO WE ALREADY HAVE THE
DID THE BUILDING DESIGNED. THIS
WOULD JUST BE THE CONSTRUCTION
SO IT'S IT'S TO CLASSROOMS AND
RESTROOMS
IN ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET.
RIGHT THERE ON PROPERTY THAT'S
ALREADY CONTROLLED BY THAT. THAT
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
SO THERE'S NO LAND COSTS.
.
AND THE DESIGN IS ALREADY.
I'M PRETTY MUCH COMPLETE IT
WOULD JUST HAVE TO BE.
UPDATED SO THERE'S VERY LITTLE
IN TERMS OF DESIGN COST AS WELL
THIS IS ALL PRETTY MUCH
CONSTRUCTION.
NO PROGRAM WHICH UP IS THE SUN
AS THE SUN BURST.
THE SUNBURST YOUTH ACADEMY WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT ARE.
HAPPY STRUGGLING THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL SAID THAT IS AN ACTUAL
PROGRAM WHERE THEY LIVE ON THE
BASE
SO THIS WAS BROUGHT FORWARD OUT
WITH FORMER SPEAKER JOHN PEREZ.
HIT THIS THIS THAT WAS THAT THE
ORIGINAL CLASSROOM CAME THROUGH
HIS INVESTMENT SO WITHOUT IS NOW
BEEN ABOUT FOUR YEARS.
AND NOW BECAUSE IT'S GROW ON THE
SECOND ASKA. IS FOR THIS
ADDITIONAL CLASSROOM.
NOW.
AND THERE'S ONLY ONE OF THESE IN
THE STATE THERE'S ONE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AS WELL FOLK AND IT'S
LOCATED IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO
NEAR.
TOLD BT COLLINS RESERVE BASE
AND.
WE HAVE AN ARMORY THERE AND
IT'S LOCATED ADJACENT TO THE
ARMY SAID ONLY HOW MANY KIDS ARE
SERVED IN THIS BUT IN THIS
PROGRAM SO RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
THREE THOUSAND.
.
STUDENTS THAT GO THROUGH EVERY
YEAR THAT GOES WITH PROGRAM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
DISTILLING THIS'LL INCREASE THAT
NUMBER TO FIVE THOUSAND TOTAL.
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON THE
IMPACT OF THE PROGRAM ON KIDS
WHEN THEY LEAVE. SO WHAT THEY
CHOOSE TO DO ARE. NOW WHAT WE
REALLY DON'T I MEAN. WE WERE
HOPING THAT
THE COURSE THE HOPE IS THAT IT
SPARKED SOMETHING IN THE STUDENT
THAT WILL.
PROP THEM TO PROCEED. WITH.
AND EDUCATION IN THE STEM.
SUBJECTS
THETEACHERS AS WELL SO THE
TEACHERS LEARN SOMETHING TO THE
TEACHERS ARE GIVEN. A CURRICULUM
AND TOOLS.
TO TAKE BACK TO THE CLASSROOM
TO TO IN TO IT ESSENTIALLY
EXTEND THE STARBASE EXPERIENCE
BACK IN THEIR SCHOOL.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE DOES
NOT KEEP STATISTICS.
ON.
ON ALL OF THE THE KIDS THAT
ATTEND THIS PROGRAM NATIONWIDE.
BUT BECAUSE IT'S BEEN FUNDED FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS.
I THINK WE CAN ASSUME THAT IT.
THAT THERE ARE THERE HAVE BEEN
STUDIES DONE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT.
OKAY I HAVE SOME DIRECT
TESTIMONY SO FROM THE TEACHERS
THAT I'VE WORKED WITH OF THE
INTO A WE ALWAYS GET. UP ASKED
TO PARTICIPATE IN VARIOUS
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
AND SOMETIMES THEY ARE AS
EXCITING AS EXPECTED AND AND THE
STUDENTS COME AWAY WITH A GREAT
EXPERIENCE AND SOMETIMES THEY'RE
NOT. THIS ONE PARTICULARLY I
KNOW THAT BECAUSE I HAVEN'T BEEN
A VENN OUT OF THE CLASSROOM SOME
OF THE TEACHERS HAVE SAID THAT
THEY FELT THAT IT'S BEEN REALLY
IMPACTFUL BECAUSE IT'S ALLOWING
THEM TO DO THINGS ON SITE THAT
THEY. CAN'T NECESSARILY DO IN A
CLASSROOM IT'S A LAB SETTING
THERE'S A ROOMS THAT ALL SO
FORTH SO.
I KNOW ONE OF GROUP MISTER
SPEAKER AND I VISITED WE WERE
REALLY IMPRESSED THEY WERE DOING
A GOOD.
HOME.
TAKING A EGG DEL ANNA. WHAT WAS
THAT PROJECT IT WAS SAID THEY
WERE PROTOTYPING A OF A VESSEL
THAT WOULD PROTECT DAY YEAH A
CHICKEN AND EGG? AS IT TRAVELED
DOWN A WIRE ABOUT TWENTY FEET
INTO A.
HARD SURFACE AND SO.
THEIR TASK WAS TO DESIGN NECK.
A VEHICLE TO CARRY THAT THE ACT
AND THEN THEY ACTUALLY WENT OUT
AND TESTED IT. AS PART OF A.
THE EXPERIMENT.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH SANTIAGO AND PATTERSON.
AND SEEMS TO PATTERSON WAS HERE.
EVERY HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROPOSAL
SUFFERING A HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SUPPOSE OFF YES YOU ENLISTED
SANTIAGO OKAY YES UP MISTER
SANTIAGO IS A PRESENTING IN TWO
OTHER. COMMITTEES I AM.
YEAH I CAN'T CAN'T MAKE IT HERE
IN TIME.
HE HAS.
DELEGATED ME TO MAKE THE
PRESENTATION AND WE CAN
INTRODUCE THE UP.
I INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL SPEAK TO
IT.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT TIME THAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THAT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
AS I MENTIONED.
.
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO WAS PRESENTING THEM IN
OTHER COMMITTEES.
WE'RE REQUESTING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS
TO GO TOWARD ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
FUNDING WILL ALSO BE USED TO TO
INCREASE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND TRAINING ON THIS ISSUE AND
TO CONDUCT A. PREVALENCE STUDY
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THIS CRIME
IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE TOP
STATES IN THE NATION FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WITH NUMBERS OF
IDENTIFIED VICTIMS.
CONTINUING TO GROW. IT IS
THROUGH THE WORK OF MANY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING CAN
BE RESCUED AND BROUGHT INTO A
LIFE OF RECOVERY.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TEMPORARY
HOUSING COUNSELING JOB TRAINING
AND THE CHANCE FOR A NEW LIFE.
THESE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
ARE CONTINUING A CONTINUOUSLY
FACED WITH BUDGET SHORTFALLS.
RIGHT NOW ORGANIZATIONS IN MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE STATE
ARE FACED WITH HAVING TO REDUCE
THEIR KEY STAFFS HOURS.
CASE WORKERS
WAITING LIST VICTIMS AND LETTING
THAT GO OFF TO OTHER.
A STAFF THE FURTHER FUNDING IS
NOT SECURED BY THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
IS BUDGET REQUEST WILL HELP
VICTIMS GET THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED.
STATE HAS APPROVED SIMILAR
FUNDING FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
WE ARE ASKING FOR MORE STATE
INVESTMENT IF WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT COMBATING. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HELPING RESTORE
THE LIVES OF SURVIVORS.
TODAY TO ORGANIZATION TO WORK TO
ASSIST VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ARE HERE THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION TO A
ABOLISHED SLAVERY AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BASED OUT OF LOS
ANGELES. AND FRESNO EEOC BASED
OUT OF MY DISTRICT THEY ARE HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS REQUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY
NAME IS MELANIE CUEVAS AND I AM
WITH THE KING TALKERS COMPANY
AND THE PRO BONO LOBBYIST FOR
THE COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
AND TRAFFICKING.
I'M CAST IS THE FIRST SERVICE
PROVIDER IN THE NATION TO SERVE
MEN WILL WOMEN AND CHILDREN
VICTIMS OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY.
OUR SERVICES INCLUDE CASE
MANAGEMENT LEGAL SHELTER AND THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR HOTLINE THAT IS
POSTED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I AM ARE POLICY PROPOSALS COME
HER BOOTS ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE SO TODAY WE ARE VERY
PROUD TO REQUEST A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR CONTINUING
APPROPRIATION. I'M AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED THIS
WOULD GO TOWARDS GRANTS FOR
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS FOR VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING. INCREASED
TRAFFIC ARE INCREASED TRAINING
FOR OUR FIRST RESPONDERS A
PREVALENT STUDY OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS AN EVALUATION OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
COSTS FOURTH YEAR WORKING ON
THIS REQUEST AND FOR THE
PREVIOUS THREE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
NEED FOR SPECIALIZED SERVICES.
AND DODD TWENTY ONE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVE NOW
BEEN FOUND DEAD. ALMOSTEVERY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA NOW HAS AT
LEAST ONE SERVICE PROVIDER THAT
IS EQUIPPED
TWO I HANDLE THE NEEDS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ON A
PERSONAL NOTE CAST IS A GRANT
RECIPIENTS. AND ARE WEAK LIST
USED TO BE A HUNDRED TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED SURVIVORS AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE WOULD WAY UP TO TWO YEARS
TO. AND RECEIVE SERVICES FROM US
AND NOW OUR WAITING LIST IS
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AND NOBODY IN
CRISIS HAS HAD TO WAIT ON A
WAITING LIST THINKS AND LARGE
PART TO THE GRANT FUNDING SCRIPT
YEAH. I'M THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS APPROVED SO FAR FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS ARE TREMENDOUS FIRST
STEP HOWEVER WE FEEL IT'S VERY
IMPERATIVE. NOW FOR THIS FUNDING
TO BE A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATE
CHEN WERE HOPING THAT WE CAN
START TO ESTABLISH A CONTINUING
FIND.
FUNDING STREAM FOR THE VICTIMS
AND FOR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS.
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE
RECEIVE THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROVAL ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE ME IF IT'S NOT.
HELLO AND I THINK HE'LL MADAM
CHAIR AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
AND SHARE TODAY. I MY NAME IS
MELISSA GOMEZ AND I AM FROM
FRESNO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
COMMISSION CENTRAL VALLEY GETS
ME TRACKING PROJECT. I'M OUR
PROJECT WAS FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHEN OUR STAFF
BEGAN TO DISCOVER THAT MANY OF
OUR YOUTH THAT WERE COMING
THROUGH OUR OWN SHELTER.
ACTUALLY BEING VICTIMIZED.
BY HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND ALSO
IN IN FORCED LABOR AS WELL. AND
I SO IS AT THAT MOMENT THAT WE
RELEASE NEED TO EDUCATE
OURSELVES AND OUR COMMUNITY TO
RESPONSE ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES
OF OUR TIME.
WITH INITIAL FEDERAL FUNDING THE
PROJECT BEGAN TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS
AND TRAINED PROFESSIONALS AND
MULTI SECTORS. AND WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING ENABLING US
TO PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES.
STRATEGICALLY WE FORMED A
REGIONAL HUB AND WE CONTINUE TO
ACT AS AN UMBRELLA TO SUB GRANT
FUNDS TO OTHER AGENCIES WHICH
ALLOWED US TO LEVERAGE THOSE
RESOURCES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ADDITIONALLY WE ESTABLISHED AND
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FREEDOM COALITION
EVALUATE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
VEHICLE SERVICE COORDINATION
BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS THE
FEDERAL AND. BUT AND LOCAL ON
FORTUNATE SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
THE FAITH BASED COMMUNITY.
WE COURTNEY A REGIONAL TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN RESPONSE FOR THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOTLINE AND
MANY SURVIVORS COME TO US WITH
ONLY THE CLOTHES ON THEIR BACKS
IN FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES AND
TYPICALLY WITH VERY LIMITED.
FAMILY SUPPORT TO DATE WE HAVE
SERVED OVER SIX HUNDRED
SURVIVORS FROM TWENTY THREE
COUNTRIES RANGING FROM THE AGES
OF TWELVE YEARS OLD SO SEVENTY
TWO.
WE COR I OUR REGION FACES
CONSIDERABLE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
WE MAKE UP SIX RURAL COUNTIES
SPANNING WERE SAID TO KERN IN
ARE PLAYED BY CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHEST RATES OF POVERTY SCHOOL
DROPOUTS IN CRIME. SERVING AS A
GATEWAY BETWEEN LOS ANGELES THE
BAY AREA LAS VEGAS AND
SACRAMENTO WERE IN THE MIDST OF
MY IDENTIFIED HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CIRCUIT.
FRESNO COUNTY. HAVE SOMEWHAT
QUICKLY VESTS.
I'M SORRY YOU COULD SUM IT UP
YES SO WE ARE HOME TO NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND IMMIGRANTS IN
OUR PRIME LOCATION FOR BOTH
LABOR AND SEX TRAFFICKING. AND I
JUST WANT TO SHARE ONE THING
SPECIFICALLY THAT BEFORE
RECEIVING THIS FUNDING WHATEVER
ROLE COMMUNITIES HAS SHARED THAT
THERE WAS NO WHERE FOR SURVIVORS
TO TURN. AND AFTER A TRAFFICKER
WAS RECENTLY SENTENCED TO LIFE
IN PRISON WE ASKED ONE OF OUR
SURVIVORS WHAT THIS FUNDING
MEANT TO HER. AND WHAT IT MEANT
TO HER TO BE FREE SHE SAID I'M
FREE TO THINK ON MY OWN TO MAKE
MY OWN CHOICES I CAN HAVE WHAT
THEY WANT IN LIFE I CAN SEE WHAT
I WANT TO BECOME. AND SO ARE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE PROJECTS SUCH AS OURS ARE
IN GRAVE DANGER ENDING A
CONTINUOUS AND STABLE FUNDING IS
NOT OBTAINED. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EYES ANYONE
IN THE AUDIENCE.
BOB THIS IS A CAST PROPOSALS
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS THIS IS CAST
YEAH THAT COALITION TO ABOLISH
THE RIGHT THINKING WE WERE FUND.
HOW DID OR YEARS WE HAVE A TEAM
OF PRO GUN LOBBYISTS AND?
MEMBERS AND.
I WAS I WAS WONDERING BECAUSE
THEN IT WOULD FUND IT CAST LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND I DIDN'T.
DIDN'T FULLY HONEST WITH BEST
MINNESOTA WITH THE SAME THING
PATH WASN'T FUNDED WE WERE WERE
A GREAT RECIPE.
OKAY ALRIGHT WELL CASTLES A PART
OF IT CRAMPON OF OKAY YEAH I
REMEMBER THAT OKAY.
LARA BECAUSE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
PROPOSALS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD DEALING WITH VERY
SIMILAR ISSUES AND SO TRYING TO
KEEP THEM ALL. AS WHICH
ORGANIZATIONS MAKING THE REQUEST
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OKAY IDENTITY TO PRESENT OWN
NO PROBLEM BECAUSE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER AND RUBIO.
THOSE NIXON'S ALSO DEALING WITH
THE.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
VIOLENCE SINCE
AND THOUGH. CHILDREN ADVOCACY
GROUP OKAY THANK YOU.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF
JOINING ME HERE TODAY SENATOR
JIM BELL BALFE I'M MICHAEL
CHAMPION IN THE SENATE FOR THIS
BUDGET REQUEST. AND I TOGETHER
WITH THE SUPPORT OF TWENTY NINE
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATORS AND OVER
ONE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF A FIFTY. MILLION
ONGOING ALLOCATION TO CREATE A
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
COMPLEMENTARY UP PREVENTION AND
SERVICE FUND ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
DESPITE A SHARP INCREASE IN NEED
AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR DOMESTIC
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE HAS REMAINED
STAGNANT OVER THE LAST DECADE.
RAPE CRISIS PROGRAMS ARE ONLY
FUNDED AT FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
SO THE NEED TO SAY THAT AGAIN
ONLY FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FURTHERMORE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROGRAMS HAVE NOT RECEIVED A
BUDGETARY INCREASE IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS. WE MUST INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE PREVENTATIVE EFFORTS
RESEARCH.
BUT ALSO HOUSING ILLEGAL
SUPPORT HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE
THE ADVOCATES WHO ARE WORKING
TIRELESSLY AND HAVE DATA TO
SUPPORT A REQUEST. THUNDER AND
BECAUSE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT. AYE
CHRIS DARDEN INSECT PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT FIRST IF I
HAVE A SENATOR BELLOW WOULD LIKE
SAFETY WORK THAT WOULD.
IF YOU DO IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF ITS
PLEASURE TO BE IN THE ASSEMBLY
HERE.
.
AND ADDING TO.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
RUBIO'S COMMENTS
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
ACOSTA HUNDRED FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND.
ONE TIME FUNDING DOES NOT
ADDRESS TO REOCCURRING COST.
AND THE NEED FOR SERVICES
WITHOUT FUNDING FOR A LONG TERM
SERVICES.
CLING FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR
HOUSING AND COMPREHENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES
SURVIVORS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CYCLE FROM ONE CRISIS TO ANACS.
SURVIVORS NEED SOLID ONGOING
FUNDING.
THE KEY INVESTMENT MAY
STRENGTHENS THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE BEYOND JUST THE MOMENT
OF CRISIS.
IT MAKES FINANCIAL SENSE TO
REDUCE THE LONG TERM COST BY
FOCUSING ON PREVENTION A
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND NOW I'M SAYING THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE. MEMBERS IT
SIGNED.
THE PETITION FOR THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OKAY THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE ON MY NAME IS SANDRA
BECAUSE SOMETIMES HE EL THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND ID LIKE TO SPEAK WITH YOU
BOTH ABOUT SEXUAL AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ON I WANTED TO START A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE IN THE PAST.
TRIED TO SEEK SUPPORT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
GENERAL FUND.
AND THAT HAS NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND SO AND NUMBER AND
TWENTY TWELVE WE COMMISSIONED.
THAN A LEADING RESEARCHER IN
THE NATION TO DO A REPORT ON
WHAT THE US.
SEXUAL VIOLENCE COST THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT CAME OUT
TO BE.
FOR TANGIBLE COST.
AND THEY WERE LOOKING AT A
SNAPSHOT OF TWENTY TWELVE.
WHERE WE? HAVE A TOTAL INCIDENT
OF RAPE OR SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT
EXCEEDED OVER ONE POINT ONE
MILLION.
AND SO IN TERMS OF THE TANGIBLE
COSTS THAT CAME TO NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT INCLUDED THINGS
LIKE. OVER NINE BILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING THINGS LIKE THE
MEDICAL HEALTH CARE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROPERTY DAMAGE
VICTIM SERVICES AND EDUCATION.
THOSE ARE DIRECT COST THAT WE
CAN TRACE ON THEM WHEN WE LOOK
AT INTANGIBLE COSTS WHICH
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE LOSS OF.
WORK PRODUCTIVITY.
GROWING EARNING LOSS WHILE
CONFINED AND LOST A QUALITY OF
LIFE LIFE THAT COMES TO.
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF THOSE
COST WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
EIGHTY NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION
SO NEARLY NINETY BILLION IS
RESULT OF SEXUAL ABUSE AGAINST
CHILDREN. IN OUR STATE.
SO.
AS.
BOTH THE SENATOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONED
ALREADY.
STATE GENERAL FUND CURRENTLY.
COMMITS ONLY FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HOW THAT HAS BEEN THE CASE FOR
MANY MANY YEARS.
.
AND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAD BENEFITED FROM.
FUNDS TO DO PREVENTION EFFORTS
AROUND THE STATE AND.
THERE WAS THE.
RE FORMULA REFORMULATION OF THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT WHICH
RESULTED IN CALIFORNIA LOSING.
A MILLION DOLLARS AND THE
RESULT OF THAT IS THAT.
EVERY COUNTY NO LONGER HAS THE
BENEFIT OF PREVENTING TRYING TO
PREVENT THIS. SO WHERE WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
REPORT ALSO REVEALS IS THAT
EVERY PREVENTED RAPE OF AN ADULT
COULD SAVE CALIFORNIA A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND EVERY
PREVENTED RAPE OF A SEXUAL
ASSAULT OF A CHILD.
SAVE CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED WE FEEL LIKE THIS IS A
PRETTY GOOD INVESTMENT BECAUSE
OF THE AMOUNT THE CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENTLY PUTTING OUT SOMEWHAT
BICU. GONNA.
WE GIVE YOU FIVE MINUTES REACH
YES FORGET OVER SOME IF YOU SOME
OF.
SO JUST QUICKLY.
IN TERMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WE BROUGHT THESE TWO ISSUES
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE.
IT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONE OF
THE LEADING CAUSES OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG WOMEN AND.
WE CURRENTLY ARE LOOKING TO
PROVIDE OTHER ADDITIONAL
SERVICES THAT WE CANNOT
CURRENTLY PROVIDE. ON WE HAVE A
HUGE FOCUS IN THIS.
REQUEST AROUND PREVENTION
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THAT IS WE
NEED TO GO UPSTREAM AND PREVENT
THIS FROM HAPPENING IN ADDITION
TO ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THOSE
THAT ARE VICTIMIZED. BUT WE NEED
TO PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING BY
WORKING ON SYSTEMS WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT POTENTIAL
VICTIMS AND PARTICULARLY.
CHANGING.
ATTITUDES IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
BOB DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT
YOU WANT TO COMMENT VERY
BRIEFLY.
JUST VESSELS CHRISTENDOM SECOND
THE POLICY MANAGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS TEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO AND CENTER ABOUT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST DO. SO THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR.
FIFTY MILLION.
SHOULD GO TO THE.
OUR OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ADMIN FOLKS WOULD APPLY FOR
GRANTS IS THAT WHAT IT WOULD BE.
OKAY WE HAVE SOMEONE TO THOSE
WHO WANT TO SUPPORT PLEASE GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND.
WHAT AGENCY YOU WITH LIZZIE DID
NOT A SILLY OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU?
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY TELL THE CALIFORNIA
PENNA THINK OF THEM WORK IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN FINLEY ALLIANCE BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR SPEAKING IN FULL
SUPPORT.
BUT IN A COUPLE SIMPLE SUPPORT.
SO SON KIM CONTRA COSTA FAMILY
JUST IT'S AN OUT IN SUPPORT.
OKAY MARIN.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK THAT IS THAT WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS THAT ARE
SIMILAR.
AND.
SEVERAL PROPOSES THE WANT TO
SEND MONEY TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THAT ARE
KIND OF TO GIVE US A WILL BE
LOOKING AT THAT AND UP.
AND ALSO IT IS THAT I'M NOT
SURE I KNOW CASTILHO SEXUAL.
TRAFFICKING AND.
AND VIOLENCE SO THERE'S SOME.
SIMILAR OVERLAP BUT NOT MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MANAGER HA.
KANSEN CHU I HAVE ONE MORE I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY THAT'S RIGHT UP
GOT.
I THINK THAT YOU CAN CHILDREN
ADVOCACY CENTER.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
JOINING ME HERE TODAY IS TO THE
FLOOR AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND FORENSIC INTERVIEW
SPECIALIST FOR THE CHILDREN
ADVOCACY CENTER. OUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING SUPPORT
OF A THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER TO
HELP WITH THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN SUPPORT FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS. LAST YEAR
THE CENTERS RESOURCES WERE
SEVERELY STRAINED AS THEY WORK
TO MEET THE GROWING NEEDS OF
AGENCIES AND FAMILIES A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. IMPACT WITHIN
THE LAST TWO YEARS THERE HAS
BEEN A FIFTY SIX PERCENT
INCREASE FOR INTERVIEW REQUEST
AN EX.
EXPECT WE EXPECT THE SIMILAR
INCREASE TOOK CURRENT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. DUE TO CONTINUED OUR
RETURN INCREASED AWARENESS
SURROUNDING THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE CENTER.
MA MANAGER WHEN I MET.
SUSIE AND VISITED THE CHILDREN
ADVOCACY CENTER I WAS VERY
TOUCHED BY THE WORK THAT THEY DO
SPECIFICALLY IN ONE SITUATION A
AYE YEAH AYE LITTLE GIRL HAD
BEEN. AYE SEXUALLY MOLESTED
SINCE SHE WAS FIVE YEARS OLD.
UP UNTIL SHE WAS TWELVE.
BY HER OWN BIOLOGIC FATHER AND
HE SAID THAT'S HOW WE DO IT IN
MY COUNTRY.
AND I I THINK THAT IS A
DISGUSTING AND I I THINK THAT.
THE WORK THAT CHILDREN ADVOCACY
CENTER IS DOING IS CRUCIAL TO
THE AWARENESS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE INCREASE AND IN CASES IS NOT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T HAPPENING IT'S
BECAUSE. CHILDREN ARE ARE BEING
EMPOWERED TO ACTUALLY SPEAK OUT
AND SUSIE AND THE CHILDREN
ADVOCACY CENTER ARE DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB AND I HAVE CITY
HERE WITH ME TO JUST SHARE A FEW
WORDS WITH YOU.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MANY
MCGINNIS WHO SEE FLOOD IS.
JUST IN BRIEF WHAT WE DO AT THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER IS WE
CONDUCT FRANTIC INTERVIEWS OF
VICTIMS OF ABUSE.
WHAT IT DOES IS A MINIMIZES BUT?
ADDITIONAL TRAUMA BECAUSE IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A ONE STOP SHOP ONE
INTERVIEW IT'S ALL RECORDED
WE'VE WE ARE A WE OPERATE ON A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM APPROACH
WHICH MEANS THAT. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE INVESTIGATIVE TEAM COME TO
OBSERVE THE INTERVIEW OF THE
VICTIMS
THEREFORE MINIMIZING MORE TRAUMA
TO THE CHILD BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE INTERVIEWED BY
MULTIPLE AGENCIES THAT INCLUDES
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF. CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES AS WELL AS
COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICES AND AGAIN
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN REQUESTS FOR
INTERVIEWS OF ALL CHILDREN.
THIS IS A PROGRAM IN IN EAST
LOS ANGELES IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THE TEARS NOT LIKE MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
THERE'S PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
COUNTY THURS FIVE BUT IN THE
EAST.
EAST LOS ANGELES WE ARE THE
ONLY ONE AND IT'S CALLED THE
CHILD AT CHILDREN'S AT PERCENT
AB ADVOCATE ANY CENTER CURRENT
OF SEVERAL CENTERS. AND THIS IS
ONE OR EXCEPT WE ARE AN
INDEPENDENT.
NATIONALLY GET CREDITED
NONPROFIT BOETTGER AND HOW YOU
FUND IT WE SEEK OLIVER FUNDING
THROUGH PRIVATE DONATIONS AND
SOME.
CORPORATE GRANTS AND AWARDS
THAT WE RECEIVE CURRENT MAP
MOCHA AND WE DON'T JUST SAY YOU
KNOW TO WE DON'T CHARGE ANY
VICTIMS ARE FAMILIES ARE EVEN
ARE YOU REFERRING AGENCIES FOR
OUR SERVICES AS WELL AND THAT'S
WHY WE ALWAYS SEEK.
.
DONATIONS FROM THE COMMUNITY
FOR BUSINESSES FROM EVERYONE SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES OKAY.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ANYBODY IN MY QUESTIONS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TO THANK YOU.
NEXUS MISTER CHIU KANSEN CHU.
THERE.
TREVOR PROTECTION.
I SEE YOU BROUGHT YOUR OWN HIM.
IF YOU BREAK IN ORDER ASIAN.
YOU THAT FIVE MINUTES TOTAL DID
TELL US WHAT YOU WANT TO LIVE
ALRIGHT BUT THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER AND MEMBERS ALSO WON'T
THINK GOOD.
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH
THOSE OF MY OFFICE ON THIS ISSUE
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR IT.
ADDICT COMMITTEE FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING OF SOME HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND FOR EACH OFF DEFY
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN MY
DISTRICT.
TO ADDRESS A CAR BREAKING IN AND
THEFT FROM BETA CHO.
BIG BIRD DID PEOPLE LIVING IN MY
DISTRICT A LIVE WITH DAILY FEAR
OF BEING THE VICTIM OF WHETHER
THE DAY SHOPPING AND VISITING A
FRIEND OR GOING EVEN TO THE PARK
OR THE POST OFFICE.
THE CRYING MY HAVE THING MINOR
COMPARED TO OTHERS BUT IT'S
REALLY AFFECTED QUALITY OF LIFE
AND ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING HARD TO JUST STAY THERE
HAD. A BROKEN WINDOW WILL MEANS
COST FOR REPAIR AND PROBABLY
INCREASING MUST INSURANCE FOR
YOU.
HERE WITH ME TODAY OUR VERY
SPECIAL GUEST FROM MY DISTRICT
WHO CAN SPEAK MORE ON THE EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEM. AND HOW
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD HELP IN
THEIR EFFORT TO COME BACK TO SEE
YOU TOO.
I HELP A CAPTAIN FOR
FRED.
A BOBBITT FROM FREMONT POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND ASSISTANT CHIEF.
THEN WINTERS FROM SANTA CLARA
AND CAPTAIN JONATHAN ALWAY
FROM NEWARK SO GENTLEMAN.
ANY ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'M
HERE TO ADDRESS OUR COMMUNITY
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTO BREAK
INS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
CITY OF FREMONT HAS EXPERIENCED
A TWENTY FOUR PERCENT INCREASE
IN THEFTS FROM VEHICLES.
JUST IN JANUARY FROM JANUARY TO
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AN
EIGHT MONTH PERIOD ONE SHOPPING
CENTER IN OUR COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCED EIGHTY THREE AUTO
BURGLARIES.
I LIKE TO SHARE ONE RECENT
COMPLEX AND EXHAUSTING
INVESTIGATION.
WHICH WAS WORKED.
THROUGH SEVERAL PARTNERS AND
AGENCIES AROUND US. WHERE WE
ACTUALLY LA IT LED TO SEVERAL
ARRESTS IN THE RECOVERY OF OVER
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED LAPTOPS AND
WIRELESS DEVICES WHICH WERE
RETURNED TO THEIR RIGHTFUL
OWNERS?
WE'VE WORKED TIRELESSLY WITH OUR
COMMUNITY CENTER COMMERCIAL
CENTERS BUSINESS OWNERS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. ARE
PREVENTIVE METHODS IN THE AREA
OF AUTO BREAK INS OF THIS BUDGET
REQUEST WILL ENHANCE OUR EFFORTS
AND OUR ABILITY TO WORK WITH OUR
PARTNER AGENCIES SHOPPING
CENTERS BUSINESS OWNERS AS WELL
AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
IT WILL ALSO GIVE US THE ABILITY
TO ADD USEFUL EQUIPMENT
EDUCATIONAL AND MARKETING
MATERIALS ENHANCE OUR OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN. AND INCREASE OUR
PRESENCE DURING CRITICAL TIMES
DURING THESE INCIDENTS
I HAD THE TIME TO SPEAK TO THE
POLICE CHIEF FROM MILPITAS WHO
ALSO WANTED TO SHARE THAT HIS
CITY HAS SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE. AND WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MADAME CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GIVING US A FEW MOMENTS OF
YOUR TIME SO WE CAN EXPRESSED
IMPORTS OF THESE FUNDS TO THE
SENATE WHERE POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE CITIZENS OF SANTA CLARA
AND THE BAY AREA. OUR CITY HAS
SEEN A SIXTY TWO PERCENT
INCREASE IN AUTO BURGLARIES AND
THEFTS FROM VEHICLES OVER THE
PAST YEAR. AND A RECENT CITYWIDE
SURVEY PROPERTY CRIMES ARE THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF OUR
CITIZENS. AND THEFTS FROM
VEHICLES WAS THE NUMBER TWO
RATED ISSUE JUST BEHIND
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARIES THIS MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING WILL HELP US FIND
MORE INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION.
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND GREATLY
ENHANCE OUR EFFORTS TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE THOSE
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
CRIMES. WILL BE ABLE TO HIRE
OFFICERS TO CONDUCT SATURATION
PATROLS CONDUCT FOR CONDUCT
PATROLS IN HIGH TARGET AREAS AND
USE PREDICTIVE POLICING MODELS
PREVENT THESE CRIMES FROM
HAPPENING. WITH THIS FUNDING THE
FIVE AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE ON EFFECTIVE CRIME
FIGHTING STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON A WHEELCHAIR
WEBER ANOTHER STEAM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JONATHAN OUR WAY WHEN I'M A
POLICE CAPTAIN FOR THE CITY OF
NEWARK. LOCATED WITHIN UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE DISTRICT
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
REGARDING THIS MATTER WE FOUND
IT'S VERY TROUBLING FOR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM OUR LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNERS AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO ARE VISITING THE BAY AREA
FOR BOTH BUSINESS AND LEISURE. I
LIKE TAKE A MOMENT TO PROVIDE
YOU LOCAL BRIEF OVERVIEW INTO
THE PLAY CAN SITUATION.
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS FROM
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE PERCENT
INCREASE AND THIS PARTICULAR
TYPE OF CRIME.
WITH TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BEING AS OUR HIGHEST
SINGLE YEAR JUMP WITH THE SIXTY
PERCENT JOB JUST IN THAT ONE
YEAR. IF YOU COMMITTEE COULD
PROVIDE US THE REQUESTED SUPPORT
IT WOULD ALLOW US THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES FOR A
SUSTAINED COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
WITH OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND REGIONAL
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS IN ORDER
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. SOME OF
THE OVER ARCHING PRONGS OF THE
SUSTAIN MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
WOULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY
AWARENESS AND PARTNERSHIPS
FOR EXAMPLE BY EXPANDING OUR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PERSONNEL
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE OUR REACH.
THROUGH CAMPAIGNS.
THROUGH LOCAL MEDIA LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUPS SUCH AS
NEIGHBORHOOD GROUPS VOLUNTEER.
CLUBS AND CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THIS IN TURN HELPS DECREASED
EXPOSURE THE VICTIMIZATION.
HI ADDING ANALYTICAL
CAPABILITIES WHICH WOULD.
WE WOULD BASE OUR POLICING FROM
OUR EFFORTS FROM IN A
COLLABORATIVE AND DIRECTED SUPER
OUR INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES. TO
IDENTIFY PROSECUTE AND
DISASSEMBLE THE SOPHISTICATED
CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE CREWS THAT
WE'VE FIGURED OUT HER. WILL NOT
NOT TO HAVE REAL BASIC.
EYES WHICH ONE WOULD THINK THAT
IF I COULD JUST ADD THAT IT FROM
A PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE FROM MY
TWENTY OVER TWENTY THREE YEARS
AND AND PUBLIC SAFETY THIS IS
PROBABLY THE WORST I'VE SEEN.
THIS TREND AND IT'S IT'S NOT
GETTING ANY BETTER.
WE HOPE YOU SUPPORT THE REQUEST
AND I DID BY CHIEF TO COME SPEAK
WITH A BURKE LOCAL LEADERS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE BUSINESS
OWNERS OUR COME ON A RIDE ALONG
WITH ANY OF US IN AND GO WILL
SHOW YOU FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE AS
WELL. ON PLEASE LET US KNOW WE
CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IN THE
FUTURE AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
FEAR.
WITHOUT THIS FUNDING HOW WOULD
YOU ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
WELL WE ARE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
OUR BEST WILL CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH ALL FIVE
AGENCIES IN OUR DISTRICT.
BY NO MEANS WILL WE.
STOP DOING WHAT WE'RE DOING WE
JUST KNOW THAT THIS WILL.
IT IT WILL GIVE US THE ABILITY
TO ENHANCE
AND ARE REALLY ALLOW ARE
VICTIMS.
AND ARE GOOD PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
JOIN OUR COMMUNITIES TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH ART BY ONE TIME
FUNDING REQUEST CORRECT.
SO OFTEN THAT'S WOULD BE A ONE
TIME FUNDING WONDER HOW DOES THE
ISSUE CONTINUE I GUESS. IS THAT
IT'S A RESOURCE IS BEING PUT
INTO.
CAMPAIGNING OR AS A SET SIGNED
SIR IS THAT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
HOME.
MUCH MORE THAN PAROLE PATROL AND
SO FORTH AND SO ON THAT WERE
THAT WAY SO THAT. YOU WILL BE
DOING A LOT OF OF COMMUNITY
OUTREACH. NO SIGNS AND CAMPAIGN
AND SO ON SO FORTH A HOPE OF.
ALSO HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO
AND INCREASED SOME AMOUNT OF
FOOD PATROL AND JUST TO TAMPER
TO THAT THERE'S STILL A BUT YOU
SHOOT DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
AND YOU HEARD THE PERCENTAGE OF
INCREASE.
MY AND ALL THAT THAT NUMBER
WILL STACK AND IN MY DISTRICT OR
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND OBTUSA.
WIDOW CHO CRIME A YEAR SO IT IT
IT DOESN'T REALLY.
EPIDEMIC WOULD REALLY NEED TO
ADDRESS IT AND PARTICULAR MUCH
FOR YOUR CALL A RACIAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK THEM DOWN.
THERE MISTER GRAYSON
.
YOU DON'T TWENTY JUSTICE CENTER.
YES.
GOOD MORNING OR AFTERNOON JULY
SAY MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE
FOR FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS ARE
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI AGENCY
CENTERS THE PROVIDE A ONE STOP
SHOP. OF SUPPORT SERVICES OF
SURVIVORS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE WHICH INCLUDES DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE ELDERLY
ABUSE AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THE DEFINING FEATURE OF THE
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER MODEL IS
THAT SURVIVORS OF DRAMATIC
EVENTS.
CAN EXCESS OF ACCESS ALL THE
CENTRAL SERVICES WITHOUT HAVING
TO TRAVEL TO VARIOUS AGENCIES
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
FAMILY COURT ASSISTANCE MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING AND HELP
OBTAINING RESTRAINING ORDERS ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE INDISPENSABLE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED UNDER
ONE ROOF.
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS SERVE THE
MOST VULNERABLE OF IN
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
TO GIVE YOU JUST A PICTURE OF
WHO THEY SERVE.
THE CONTRA COSTA FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER EIGHTY ONE PERCENT OF
THEIR CLIENTS HAVE A PRIOR
HISTORY WITH CUSTODY OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SEVENTY SIX PERCENT HAVE
CHILDREN.
IT'S THE FIVE PERCENT EARN LESS
THAN TWO THOUSAND PER MONTH AND
TWENTY ONE PERCENT HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO MEDICAL INSURANCE.
BECAUSE OF THIS YOU'VE SEEN THAT
WE'VE GARNERED THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT OF DOZENS OF MEMBERS AND
SENATORS WHO HAVE FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS IN SIXTEEN COUNTIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE ALL AGREE THAT THE ONLY WAY
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
SERVICES AT FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS IS WITH THE REQUISITE
STATE SUPPORT.
TO ADDRESS THIS GAP WE'RE
PROPOSING THE CREATION OF A
SEPARATE DEDICATED FUNDING
CATEGORY FOR FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS UNDER CAL O. YES.
THE PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS TOTALING TEN
MILLION PER YEAR TO THE TWENTY
ONE AND COUNTING FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WILL NOW TURN OVER MIGHT NOT THE
REST OF TIME JUSTICE ON CAM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CONTRA
COSTA FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER WHO
WILL EXPLAIN WHY FUNDING. IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED FOR THE
FAMILY JUSTICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME ASSIST
SON KIM I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONTRA COSTA FAMILY JUSTICE AT
ALL. I'M A FORMER LEGAL AID
LAWYER. WHO USED TO REPRESENT
THE MASSIVE BOMB SURVIVORS IN
FAMILY LAW MATTERS AND I MOVE
FROM LEGALLY TO THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN THE HOLISTIC MODEL?
OF PROVIDING SERVICES TO OUR
CLIENTS.
AND AS YOU NOTICED EARLIER TODAY
THERE WERE MANY SPEAKERS WHO
SPOKE ABOUT THE MISSING VIOLENCE
SEXUAL VIOLENCE TELL DEBUTS IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE THAT REALLY CONNECTED
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT OR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE A CONNECTED THEY CAUSE
TRAUMA AND THEY ALSO CAUSE.
MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
AND THE IDEA OF THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER IS THROUGH THE
SIMPLE WE PROVIDE ONE STOP
SERVICES.
AND WE HAVE GROWN IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN LET ME OPEN. WE SERVED
UP ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED FAMILIES
TWO YEARS LATER IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE WERE ABLE TO SERVE
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED PACKED
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT CHILD
ABUSE ELDER ABUSE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND ALL OF THESE
NUMBERS HAVE GROWN BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITY AWARENESS HAS GONE AND
ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
BUT
SERVICES WITHOUT ANY BARRIERS
INCLUDING GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION ON
THE LANGUAGE IMMIGRATION STATUS
NO MATTER WHAT YOUR BACKGROUND
IS WE ARE ABLE TO SERVE THIS
CLIENTS.
AND ALSO WE DO THIS WITH FORTY
DIFFERENT PARTNERS THAT INCLUDE
FOUR DIFFERENT POLICE AGENCIES.
COMMUNITY PARTNERS ADVOCACY
GROUPS AS WELL AS WE HAVE A FREE
MEDICAL CLINIC PROVIDING FREE
MEDICAL CARE.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE DRAPER OUT
SERVICES.
AND AS YOU MAY KNOW THAT THE
FAMILY JUSTICE MODEL HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED A BEST PRACTICE BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND THERE'S ALSO STATE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENABLING
LEGISLATION DEFINING THE FAMILY
JUSTICE MODEL.
AND WE HAVE SEVERAL RESEARCH
PAPERS AND REPORTS THAT SHOWED
THAT THIS PRODUCT THIS MODEL
WITH THE SUCCESSFUL AND THIS IS
THE ONE OF THE REPORT THAT I TOO
HAVE MY PHOTO. THAT I WOULD JUST
BRING THAT.
AND THERE ARE TWENTY ONE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT.
THE NUMBER IS GROWING AND WE ARE
SEEING A LOT MORE LOCATIONS AND
MORE AREAS WHERE THEY ARE.
PLANNING TO OPEN A FAMILY
JUSTICE THAT UP BECAUSE THIS ONE
STOP MODEL WOULD IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE AND HE'S MAKES SENSE.
OKAY.
ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE SEVENTY
COMMENTS.
CONCERNING THIS.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES I THINK
WILL FACE IS THAT WE HAVE A.
.
A NUMBER OF YOU KNOW A REQUEST
STRUCTURES THAT PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT AND. WITH ITS CAST WITH
ITS THIS JUSTICE CENTER WHETHER
AT SOME.
THE FAMILY.
WHAT IS AT THE? END OF THE
PROGRAM WE HAD IN LA COUNTY.
CHILDREN'S OF IN THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY CENTER SO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF. THESE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE ALBEIT IT SEEMED TO BE.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT
MISSION MAYBE OVERLAPPING IN
SOMEONE'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW THEY'RE ALL RELATED TO EACH
OTHER EVERYBODY SEEMS TO NOT?
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE ADDRESSING
THE SAME ISSUE WHICH MEANS
ISSUES MUST BE VERY VALID NEVER
COMMUNITY BUT THE BEST WAY TO TO
HANDLE IT AT THIS LEVEL AT THE
STATE LEVEL. IN TERMS OF.
.
ANYWAY WE'LL WE'LL THINK ABOUT
IT BEST WAY TO HANDLE IT MAY END
UP BEING SOME GRANT PROCESS THAT
EVERYBODY JUST SUPPLIES TO
BECAUSE THEY ALL SEEM TO BE
OVERLAP IN WITH THE. SAME ISSUES
OF OF OF VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. OF
THAT ARE ALL. VERY AND AND
SEVERAL AGENCIES ARE DRESSING IT
FROM DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
OF SO IT'S GREAT CIPTA AND I'M
NOT SURE IF WE WANT TO FUND.
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT WAYS OF DOING
THINGS SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR
RATHER ESPECIALLY THAT STATE
LEVEL WHO WANT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY IN COORDINATION.
AND ONE MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
AREA IS COVERED IN THE STATE
RATHER THAN JUST. INDIVIDUAL
AREAS ARE COVERED AND OF THE
JUSTICE AND AS YOU HAVE SEVERAL
THROUGHOUT THE STATUS ALTHOUGH
BUT THAT THE MATERIAL WAS SO.
IT'S INTERESTING BUT WILL LOOK
AT IT MIA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK MR CUNNINGHAM
IS HE HERE.
OH YES OKAY VARIOUS OPEN.
THANK YOU MAY BE OUR LAST PERSON
THAT I KNOW OF THAT I STILL MY
PIECE OF PAPER. OKAY.
AB CROSS THAT EVERYBODY YEAH
YOU'RE THE PERSON WAS HERE.
ALONE.
COVER YOUR OVERSEE EARLIER
TALKING ABOUT THE VIP PROGRAM
IN.
CAL GROUPS YES
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
UNDERSTAND I AM A BIT LATE TO
THE PARTY BECAUSE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER CAVALERA WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE SEVEN DON'T HAVE ANY
MONEY IT SO WELL DON'T
UNDERSTAND TIME.
I LIKE HER FUNDING ABOUT BETTER
ACTION THAT I WILL BE BRIEF
THOUGH THIS PROGRAM WHICH USED
TO BE CALLED THE GRIP PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA GET GANG REDUCTION
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. HAS BEEN RENAMED THE
CALVET PROGRAM VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PREVENTION.
.
I UNDERSTAND IN THE LAST BUDGET
WAS FUNDED AT NINE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL.
THE I JUST WANNA MAKE THREE
IMPORTANT QUICK POINTS ABOUT.
THIS PROGRAM FOR ONE THING IT'S
IT'S TO
PROACTIVE IN NATURE AND IT'S ONE
OF THE.
ONE OF THE PRECIOUS PROGRAMS WE
HAVE IN THE STATE THAT ACTUALLY
IS OUT IN THE COMMUNITY IN A
PROACTIVE WAY TRYING TO.
I'D GET KIDS BEFORE THEY GET
TRAPPED IN SITUATION
THAT WINDS THEN AND. IT ENDS UP
WITH THEM GOING SOMEWHERE THAT
ISN'T POSITIVE FOR THEM AND IT
HAD INCREDIBLE SUCCESS I'VE GOT.
ONE CITY AND MY DISTRICT.
CITY NAME MOM POKE.
BOB POKE FUN AT A PROGRAM TWENTY
FOUR. AT TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THEY HAD FIFTY KIDS
ENROLLED IN THEIR GRIP WHAT USED
TO BE THE GRIP FUNDED. A YOUTH
CORPS PROGRAM.
AND THEY SAW IT MASSIVE DECLINES
MASSIVE DECLINES.
IN PROBATION REFERRALS BOTH IN
ABSOLUTE TERMS AND RELATIVE TO
CONTROL GROUP THEY'RE ACTUALLY
TRACKING IT.
COMPARED TO.
GOT A CONTROL GROUP KIDS.
WERE TALKING THREE FOUR TIMES
THE THE NUMBER OF DECLINE SO WE
KNOW THE PROGRAMS EFFECTIVE WE
KNOW THAT IT WORKS
WE KNOW THAT IT IT.
.
GETS KIDS OPPORTUNITY FOR JOB
FOR JOB TRAINING AND SKILLS
DEVELOPMENT
AS WELL AS RE ENTRY AND OTHER
TYPES OF SUPPORT THINGS THAT I
THINK IT'S WORTHY OF.
CONSIDERATION FOR CONTINUED
SUPPORT.
CAN I WITH ME TODAY WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE IS AT WOULDN'T WEAVER
AND MY LEFT.
MR WEAVER'S A FRIEND OF MINE
HE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED FIGHTING
BACK SANTA MARIA VALLEY IT'S A
NONPROFIT HE STARTED. A TO
PROMOTE.
HEALTHY AND SAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR KIDS AND ALSO FOR IT'S AN
ANTI VIOLENCE PROGRAM HE YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK FOR A MINUTE IF
YOU GUYS ARE THE CHAIR NOTHING.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND LIKE
MANY CITIES IS WE'RE TRYING TO
GET AHEAD OF.
.
THE VIOLENCE CURVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE HEARD FORCE
TREATMENT AFTER THE FACT AND WE
DON'T REALLY LIKE TO START
SPENDING MONEY ON IT BUT I
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
WE WERE RAVAGED BY.
TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY ONE MURDERS AND FOURTEEN
MONTHS IT WAS EIGHTY PERCENT
HIGHER THAN.
THE STATE OF THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IN SANTA MARIA.
THE FIRST MURDER WAS HAPPY EARLY
MON HEAVIER WAS A CLIENT OF MINE
WHEN I WAS A CHILD WELFARE CPS I
WAS THE SUPERVISOR THERE AT THE
TIME.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY ARE GOT CAUGHT
UP IN THE GANG LIFE HE WAS MOST
SUPPLYING HIS OWN HABIT.
WITH METHAMPHETAMINES ANY
COULDN'T PAY THE BILLS CAN PASS
TAXES SO.
HE WAS ORDERED MURDERED FROM
PRISON BY A LOCAL GANG.
AND HIS BODY LEFT OUT AND
GUADELOUPEAN THE FARMS.
I THINK OF HOW THE AREA.
TWO DAYS AGO AS WITH LITTLE
YOUNG MAN NAMED THIS TRAIL IS
TRAIL. HAD STOPPED GOING TO
SCHOOL IS IN THE SEVENTH GRADE.
AND I WHEN I SAID KAREN ASKED AS
HE SPEAKS
HIS MOM ONLY SWISS MISS STUCCO
IT'S A DIALECT OF SOUTHERN.
MEXICO IS NOT ENGLISH IT'S NOT
SPANISH AND.
S. IS MY WHITE WHY DID YOU MOVE
HERE WAY WORKING SO HARD IN THE
IN THE FIELDS TO PROVIDE YOU
KNOW FOR YOUR SON AND SHE GOES I
WANT A BETTER LIFE FOR HIM.
IT'S TRUE IS BORN IN TE UNITED
STATES IS SAID IS THE UNITED
STATES.
AND SO.
I SAID YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA GO TO
SCHOOL I'VE TAKEN HIM ON A
COUPLE FIELD TRIPS AND HUNG OUT
WITH A LITTLE BIT. AN E.
BASICALLY LOOKS AT ME WHAT THE
* DO YOU CARE ABOUT WHAT I DO.
.
AND HE'S RIGHT WHY SHOULD I
CARE.
WHY SHOULD THE STATE CARE?
BUT IS ONE OF OURS AND I'M
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT HIM.
NOW FIGHTING BACK WILL APPLY FOR
CALVET FUNDS WE PROBABLY WON'T
GET IT BECAUSE IT CAN BE A LOT
OF PEOPLE APPLYING FOR BECAUSE
OF A LOT OF NEED STATEWIDE. BUT
WE WOULD LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY FOR THE FUNDS TO HELP KIDS
LIKE IT'S TRAIL.
TO PREVENT HIM IN BECOMING
HEAVIER.
WE CAN'T DO THAT IF YOU DON'T
RELEASE THE FUNDS
I AM IT'S A COMPETITIVE PROCESS
IT'S EQUITABLE. WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD INVESTMENT IT'S NOT A LOT
OF MONEY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATE BUDGET. AND IN ALL CITIES
ITEM UNFORTUNATE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE THIS PROBLEM AND
THEY'RE ALL ASKING YOU FOR THE
SAME THING WOULD YOU LET US GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE. INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO KEEP.
A PROVIDING SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
AFTER THE FACT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME GOT TOUGH
DECISIONS LOTS OF GOOD PROGRAMS
I DON'T ENVY YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SHARING YOUR
STORY WITH YOU IS TESTIMONY. TO
ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
IT ANY COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU I AM NOT SURE
WITH YOU INCOME A YEAR AGO DUE.
TO SOMEONE SAID MAYBE COMING
TOGETHER ONCE FOR NINE MILLION
LINES FOR EIGHTEEN WHO DO YOU
PREFER EATING HER OVERNIGHT I
SORT OF LIKE A NUMBER THAT. I
THINK OF IT I THINK THE NEEDS
THERE YEAH OKAY AND AND THEN WE
FOUND OUT ALSO THAT THE THAT.
THE PROGRAM IS STILL IN
EXISTENCE FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS
ON THE STANCE OF THIS WHAT.
A EXTEND THE TIME OF JUST
OVERLAP ON THE TIME BECAUSE I
THINK THE THE NINE MILLION IS
FOR. THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR.
I MY UNDERSTANDING SO THIS
REQUEST IS FOR.
THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR IS IT FOR AT
THEM WE NEED SOME CLARITY ON
THAT.
WHAT THEY DIDN'T SPECIFY SO
WE'LL HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT I
BELIEVE HER REQUEST WAS FROM?
THREE YEARS.
RIGHT WELL I DON'T KNOW THIS I'M
NOT SO BROUGH IN A CYCLE OF TWO
NOW THAT STILL IS THERE SO.
WE'LL HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT THEY
DIDN'T IT DIDN'T SPECIFY WHEN
THE REQUEST WAS
EVEN ONE OF YOUR REQUEST AND
SPECIFY WHAT YEAR. BECAUSE GET
W. IN A CYCLE NOW WHERE WE HAVE
ANOTHER YEAR OF THE FUNDING.
INSIDE NOT SURE WHETHER THIS IS
TO.
GO ON TOP OF THAT AND SO
THEREFORE IMMEDIATELY THERE
WOULD BE AN INCREASE OF WHETHER.
IT'S A IS SAID LOOK DOWN THE
ROAD FOR THREE YEARS SO THAT
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT FOUR TO
FIVE.
BECAUSE WE ARE HAVE TO SO.
NOT RIGHT SURE PROBABLY HAVE
TALKED WILL FEED SEEKS ACT LIKE
WHAT I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH HER
WE CAN OKAY CERTAINLY HELPFUL
OKAY I I I WOULD HAVE ONE SMALL
REQUEST I KNOW THAT IT WILL A
LOT OF PRINTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN RURAL AND
LARGER URBAN AREAS I WOULD ASK
THAT THERE WOULD BE A RURAL AREA
ADDED TO THAT THIS LAST
ITERATION OF IT. DID GO TO LARGE
URBAN AREAS WHICH HAVE A HAVE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS AND EXTEND IT.
BUT YOUR MONEY GOES A LONG WAY
IN A SMALL CITY LIKE SANTA MARIA
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE OTHER
FLINT PHILANTHROPIC RESOURCES
THAT SOME OF OUR LARGER CITIES
HAVE. SO WE COULD REPEAT THE WE
COULD REALLY USE THE HELP I AND
I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY SAYS THAT
BUT. TO ADD THE ROLE COMPONENT
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
SMALLER TOWNS LIKE OURS.
BECAUSE WE WE HAVE NO OTHER
RESOURCES OTHER THAN FROM YOU
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU PRODUCTIVE.
I THINK THAT.
BUT TODAY I THINK WE'VE HEARD
FROM.
ALL OF THOSE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
REQUEST LEE QUEST IN I THINK WE
STILL HAVE SOME MORE TO GO.
WE HAVE.
SO SOME OF THE REQUEST THOUGH
AS.
TWO MEMBERS WHO WOULD NOT HURT
YOUR REQUESTS SPENT THE WEEK
KNOWING YOU WERE GOING TO DO IT
AGAIN I THINK NEXT WEEK TO HEAR
THE OTHER REQUEST. BUT I THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.
WELL IT WOULD HAVE.
WE STILL HAVE THE RAIL OPEN.
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT VOTED.
COULD WE FIND OUT IF THEY'RE
COMING TO VOTE MISTER STONE AND
MISS MELINDA'S.
SO ARE.
COMMITTEE THEN COMMITTEE.
AND.
YOUR BILLS ARE OUT SO.
WILL WILL ADJOURN.
MEETINGS AT YOUR
FOR MRS STONE TO VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE.
HE'S IT I'D THAT MAKES IT FOUR
ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
IT MAKES IT FOUR ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWO.
ITEM NUMBER THREE WITNESSES
DON'T.
AYE THAT MAKES IT FOR HIS ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
MAKES IT FOUR TO ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. OF ITEM NUMBER
FIVE.
MAKES IT FIVE TO FOUR ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE.
ITEM SIX.
I HOPE IT MAKES IT FOUR ZERO
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
MAKES IT FOUR ZERO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN.
A MAN WHO.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
I'VE THAT MAKES IT FOUR ZERO AND
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
THAT MAKES IT FOUR ZERO ITEM
NUMBER NINE.
OKAY SO MISTER STONE IS VOTE I
OWN ALL OF THE ISSUES IN THEIR
ALL OUT ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE.
THANK YOU MEETING IS ADJOURNED
AGAIN